so auf geht's ja die distro sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus zumal es eine artsch basierte distro
ist bin ich mal gespannt ihr wisst ich bin ja schon eine weile ziemlich eingefahren auf mancharo
mit die drei wm gefällt mir am besten und ich werde es auch nicht ablösen dadurch ziemlich
sicher egal was da rauskommt aber es schadet ja nichts nicht mal ein bisschen umzugucken was es
so gibt also hannah montana linux bringt ja gar nichts ich verstehe dass das ich verstehe dass
es als als gag gemeint ist aber das ist komplett unsupported irgendwie seit vier jahren oder so
so was hast du dir eigentlich schon pop os pop os haben wir uns mal angeguckt vor einem jahr oder so
das hat mich
jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig überzeugt kann ich noch daran erinnern das war so ein ding was glaube ich
also ich bin nicht ganz sicher ob das jetzt wieder richtig zusammen krieg aber das sah optisch auf
den ersten blick ganz gut aus aber sobald du eine schicht weiter unter die haube geguckt hast das
festgestellt sind wir nicht so richtig durchdacht gewesen also was was probieren wir aus also also
ich ich würde fast sagen okay das ist das ist das ist die beliebteste wie es aussieht
gold trends night was hier los wollen die hier irgendwelche minderheiten hier was was ist hier
los anzeige ist raus kann das trends night heißen einfach so gleich abmahnung los schicken gleich
berechtigungsbeauftragte ist informiert so also entweder nehmen wir das da xfc trends night okay
wir nehmen das das scheint ja mehr oder weniger so habe ich habe ich das nicht letzten sogar schon
runtergeladen
habe ich das nicht kannst du mir nicht so ganz entscheiden doch ich habe so sagt ja schon
runtergeladen ach nee ist bis die aktuelle okay da warten wir bis runtergeladen sind löschen das
alte hat ja nix sie platz machen da kann ich bei der gelegenheit nämlich auch einfach mal
ein paar alten walter vms ja und danach probieren wir auf jeden fall auf jeden fall einmal einen von
denen ach da habe ich es runtergeladen da was
danach probiere ich auf jeden fall mal eins von den tiling window managern aus das wird aber
bissl abgedrehter ich wette mit euch kann das nicht bedienen weil ich hab weder bis wm noch
herzluft wm ich vermute war dass das herzluft und der name schon alter herzluft wm wer hat sich das
denn ausgedacht das klingt überhaupt nicht stoff mäßig genug das muss heute hyper experience window
manager heißen oder so dann ist das dann ist das gut ja die sollen mal die sonnt известigen stoffen
ein paar namen empfehlen du checkst gar es gibt noch gar nichts zu checken unterm strich wir laden
uns der aktuelle linux distribution runter die jetzt erst rausgekommen ist von einer weile und
gucken uns mal ob man damit klar kommt das ist oder sind und zweck der ganzen sache block chain
wm das ist auch gut block chain wm was passiert ein paar block chain wm jeder klick löst irgendeine
anonyme bitcoin wobei bitcoin transaktion sind ja nicht so wirklich an und was ist denn das für
farbenblinde moment jetzt jetzt mal ernsthaft man kann eine krankheit haben dass man das besser
lesen kann als dass ich das ich meine das sieht einfach nur total unförmig aus ok moment das hat
nichts mit farbenblindheit zu tun das ist für leute die probleme haben wörter richtig zuzuordnen
und sowas big brain chat sind wir jetzt mal auf die linux distribution runter und gucken uns mal
was passiert mit dem chat der chat der chat muss man wieder mal alles erklären big brain chat und
das ganz ohne prime subs heute schon gibt es ja heute also der iq muss weiter steigen gar nicht
überfüllt mein desktop das absicht ich weiß ich lasse den auch so weil ich weiß dass der chat
mein desktop mag übrigens der desktop ist schon so voll ich weiß nicht ob es euch auffällt aber wenn ich hier die maus drüber bewege seht ihr hier ist alles flüssig und hier laggt das
hier ist alles flüssig und hier laggt das hier ist alles flüssig und hier laggt das
hier ist alles flüssig und hier laggt das
erkennt man dass
es laggt voll dieses markieren ich werde an was haben die sich von microsoft
erkennt man das jetzt laggt voll dieses markieren ich werde an was haben die sich von microsoft
gedacht dominance kann ich nicht 150 desktop symbole tes
i crimes
betrieben
Spielst du noch PoE?
Denkst du, äh, die Season
hab ich nicht gespielt, ne? Und, ähm,
die haben ja auch die nächste Season auf irgendwie Mitte
Januar oder so verschoben, also insofern
pff, juckt mich gerade, also
pff, ja.
Egal. Kannst du mal
Roomtour machen von deinem Schreibtisch?
Ja, ich will ja insgesamt mal Haustour machen,
weil ja viele auch schon gefragt haben, wie das mit
Heimautomatisierung aussieht und wie es
jetzt nach der Baustelle aussieht und sonst was.
Ähm, aber da muss ich halt gucken,
dass ich nicht zu viel reveale. So, okay,
TrueNAS können wir wegschmeißen, das gibt's gar nicht mehr.
Das haben wir mal ausprobiert, aber jetzt
ist fort. Oh.
Appears to be in use?
What the fuck?
Moment. Moment, wo liegt
die angeblich?
Wartet mal. Open VM Directory?
Documents, Virtual Machines?
Was? Tatsächlich?
Null. Und warum
hab ich die, vor allem warum hab ich die auf C
und nicht sonst wo?
Hier haben wir irgendein olles Ubuntu rumfliegen.
Das muss ich mal alles wegschmeißen.
Das verbraucht unnötig Festplattenplatz.
Das kommt jetzt alles weg.
Das ist bestimmt auch in use.
Das ist bestimmt auch in use. Hä?
Was hat das denn für Schmerzen?
Darf ich nicht löschen? Na gut.
Darf ich das wenigstens löschen?
E-Doppelpunkt-VMs, wobei
das könnten wir einfach verwenden. Das verwenden wir jetzt einfach.
Das verwenden wir. Was haben wir denn?
4G RAM,
4 CPU, 4 CPU-Kerne.
Okay, wenn wir 4 CPU-Kerne haben, dann können wir auch 4 CPU-Kerne haben.
Auch YOLO-Style machen. Einfach mal 8 GB RAM.
Plus, dass
das jetzt, äh,
Rename Hef
Heftorts
ist.
Oh, es gibt Subs.
Ich hab's gar nicht gesehen.
Henry2777, Twitch Prime, danke für den Sub.
Massive IQ++ für den Chat.
Take Ownership klappt bei mir immer nicht.
Guck, ich zeig's dir.
Ich hab die Meldung auch öfters und es geht bei mir nie.
Da sagt er, die VM gibt's nicht.
Wenn ich neu starte, dann geht alles.
Weiß nicht, was der für Schmerzen hat.
Ja, Henry, danke für den Sub.
Hab ich trotzdem irgendwas übersehen?
Hast du das Video-Reihe von Microsoft
Engineer gesehen, der den Windows-Taskmanager
gecode hat? Nee, ich dachte,
das ist extrem langweilig.
So, weil der Taskmanager,
was könnte an Windows uninteressanter sein
als der Taskmanager?
Wobei halt, wobei es durchaus
sein kann, dass es doch spannend ist, aber ich
fand halt, es sah nicht spannend aus.
Chat, seid ihr überhaupt
schon jetzt endlich eingehackt
hier auf die IP?
Also, ich hätt jetzt eigentlich gedacht, der Chat braucht
nicht so lang dafür. Wie gesagt,
PoE hab ich die Season nicht gespielt.
Sonst hab ich Chat durchgescrollt.
Heftor Hype? Echt? Ich kenn das nicht.
Das soll angeblich eine der
Distros sein, die gut aussehen.
Was ja meistens darauf rausläuft,
dass die oberste, der alleroberste
Layer hübsch gemacht
ist und der Rest halt nicht richtig funktioniert.
Zumindest war das bisher meine Erfahrung
mit so Polish-Distros.
Deepin mal außen
vor. Deepin, auch wenn es der China
Linux ist, macht tatsächlich einen ganz guten Eindruck.
So. Heftor.
Da sind wir. Ist der Download
fertig? Jawoll. Bam.
Heftor XFCE. Auf geht's.
Oh, Moment. Hab ich das jetzt grad an
TrueNAS drangehängt? Nee.
Nee, hab ich nicht. Wann kommt denn eigentlich
das nächste
Windows-Update? Ist das jetzt nicht irgendwann
soweit? Also sprich, das müsste ja dann
2021 H1
sein. Ah, First Half.
Okay. Ich dachte, das kommt immer ziemlich am Anfang
des Jahres raus.
What's new? Die wissen jetzt schon, was neu ist
in 21H1?
Neue Emojis. Ja, es wird ja auch
Zeit. Übrigens, hier neue
Emojis. Wusstet ihr, dass Microsoft
Jetzt passt mal auf.
Microsoft hat
Custom Emojis. Hipster Cat.
Gibt's nur unter Windows.
Hipster Cat gibt's nur unter Windows.
Hacker Cat gibt's auch. Hacker Cat gibt's auch
nur unter Windows.
Also sprich, Microsoft hat's mittlerweile
geschafft, sogar proprietäre
Emojis einzubauen in Windows.
Da hat die Welt
drauf gewartet.
Ja, guckt mal. Hier.
So sieht's halt unter Windows aus. Und jetzt?
Achso, nee.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal Heftorz starten,
dass ich euch das unter den Links zeigen kann.
Edit mal Microsoft.
Okay, bla. Haben wir
geedit. Zack. Power on.
Ja, wir haben proprietäre...
proprietäre Emojis jetzt. Allerdings
muss man echt mal Microsoft zugutehalten.
Ups. Äh.
Fette.
Kacknoob. Ah.
Ich war zu langsam. Ich weiß, dass man das
nicht braucht, aber ich mach das immer
so reflexmäßig. Ah, zu langsam.
Ich weiß, dass das anders geht.
Ah, exzellent. Aber ich freu
mich immer, wenn ich den Disputmenü erwische.
So, also. Zeig mal her.
Stretch Guest.
Respekt. Okay.
Also, was kann man zur Auswahl zu booten?
Ganz normal Install Medium. Boot.
Traffic Save. Okay, also geht nur das da.
Schauen wir mal.
Mit Windows Key Plus, ob die Emojis da drin sind.
Müssen wir mal gucken. Ich würde jetzt mal fast vermuten.
Ja.
Ja. Sind sie.
Neues Hexor Linux. Ich kenn's nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Aktuell ist
Black Screen Linux angesagt.
Oh, fuck. Darf man das überhaupt sagen?
Ein Black...
Black Screen Linux könnte ja schon...
Ist ja schon fast rassistisch
hier. Kann man das
Black Screen... Mein
Blue Screen ist ja okay, aber...
Toss. Alter. Ganz knapfer.
Wann ist raus?
So. Also, was wollen die von mir?
Hast du vorhin
BF4? Was BF4? Du meinst BF3.
Äh, ja hab ich.
Ähm. Vor ein paar Stunden
oder so. Ja. Okay, das
sieht auf jeden Fall schon mal fancy aus.
Es ist Saturday,
2. Januar. Das ist schon mal richtig.
Okay, also
installieren wir das erstmal. Was sie
natürlich wieder überhaupt nicht hinkriegen,
ist ordentlich lesbare Kontraste.
Ja. Man muss
nämlich dazu sagen, Dark
Theme allein ist überhaupt nicht
das, was es ausmacht. Wichtig ist,
dass man immer noch alles gut lesen kann. Ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen, also, bisschen anstrengend
ist es auf Dauer schon.
Also, welcome to Hexor
Linux. Clean
Computer with gparted before
installing. Okay.
Calamares Installation.
Okay, wir sollen den Computer
cleanen, sagt er. Dann run
gparted und cleanen alles.
Excellent. FAT32.
Igitt. Warum denn FAT32?
Alles weg hier.
Delete.
Accept. Jawohl, alles gelöscht.
Excellent.
Kann nichts mehr schief gehen.
Okay, das ist überhaupt nicht,
überhaupt gar nicht aus, also
die Farben und die Dinger und die Knubbel,
die sind überhaupt nicht inspiriert aus
Mac OS oder so.
Wobei, unter Mac sind die Dinger links, oder?
Ihr wisst, ihr kennt das
wahrscheinlich besser. Ich benutze Mac
äußerst selten. Unter Mac sind die links, oder?
Jap. Okay.
Chat kennt sich aus.
Excellent.
Excellent Chat.
Okay, Calamares.
Okay, da hört es mit Darkstream schon mal an.
Guck dir mal, der sieht schon gar nicht mehr so
passend aus jetzt.
Okay, American English.
Nein, British English.
Bitteschön. Wobei, American English
ist bei der Sprache okay, aber bei den Einheiten
hätte ich gerne nicht
Kokona Freedom Units,
weil da wird das Gewicht von einer Maus
bei Amazon auch noch in Ounces gemessen
und sowas.
Man weiß ernsthaft, jemand,
wie viel Ounces
ein Gramm sind und wie viel Gramm
man für ein Ounce
braucht, was auch immer.
Übrigens, aber wisst ihr, was ich
weiß? Und jetzt mal Chat IQ
Test. Wenn das fehlschlägt,
brauchen wir noch mindestens 12 Prime Subs,
um das wieder aufzuwiegen.
Wie viel...
Wie viel Watt
sind ein PS? Wird gegoogelt.
120? Nein.
Ganz weit weg von...
Kann man das umrechnen?
Ja, so halbwegs.
Ein Mitch, das ist gar nicht
schlecht. Das geht in die richtige
Richtung.
Das Problem ist, ich bin mir jetzt auch
gerade jetzt, wo ich das gefragt habe, gar
nicht mehr so hundertprozentig sicher.
Ich glaub auch irgendwas um 750
oder so. Okay, gucken wir
mal kurz.
Gucken wir mal, guck mal.
Okay, 735.
Clocks HD hat gewonnen.
Excellent.
Aber es waren, es waren doch, es waren ein paar nah dran.
Lass ich durchgehen, Chat.
Prime Subs waren erfolgreich.
Fragt mal jetzt mal
ohne Mist, ne. Ich sag das ja gar nicht,
um beim Chat zu schleimen immer.
Fragt jeden anderen
Twitch Chat, was das ist.
Und keiner ist
auch nur in der Nähe.
Ich wette mit euch.
Das müsste man ausprobieren.
Geht mal in den XQC Chat.
Wobei, der Typ ist nicht doof.
Ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, der könnte das wissen.
Der kann sich sehr viel, sehr viel
unsinnige Sachen merken.
Okay, next.
Also was, was möchte ich haben?
Kernel without any Nvidia.
Gut, in der VM habe ich kein Nvidia.
LTS.
Ja, ohne Nvidia.
Unbedingt.
Weiß zwar nicht, ehrlich gesagt, so genau
warum das relevant ist.
Aber okay.
Kernel ohne Nvidia in der
VM ist es eh egal.
Communication Software.
Discord.
Das ist ja die erste Distro, die
mich fragt, ob ich Discord installieren
will. Das finde ich eigentlich gar nicht
so schlecht.
Was soll ich für Manjaro i3
bei VMware für eine Linux Version auswählen,
sofern das relevant ist?
Ich glaube, ich habe einfach das ganz
normale
anderes Linux
4er Kernel oder 5er Kernel
oder so ausgewählt. Man kann nicht
sagen.
Ich glaube, ob man das hier überhaupt sieht.
Ich glaube, das sieht man hier gar nicht.
Letztendlich ist es ziemlich egal.
Ah, hier.
Andere Linux 5er
oder späterer Kernel habe ich ausgewählt.
Das macht aber keinen großen
Unterschied.
Kann man auch, Discord kann man auswählen.
Qtalks.
Das sagt mir irgendwas.
Das ist irgendein,
was es auch schon eine Weile gibt,
ein Messenger oder sowas.
Ich bin mir da aber nicht ganz sicher.
Ein
Mitch fragt, bin ich mittlerweile der Einzige, der noch
Teamspeak benutzt? Nee.
Wisst ihr was, Leute?
Wir machen mal kurz
den Browser auf.
Da, wo ich noch viel MMOs
gespielt habe, damals haben
die Deutschen haben immer
Teamspeak
verwendet. Ein paar Abgedrehte
haben Mumble verwendet, falls
das noch jemand kennt. Aber die Deutschen
haben immer Teamspeak verwendet. Und wisst ihr,
was die Amis verwendet haben?
Was meint ihr, was die
Amis damals, also die
englischsprachige Community,
Froggy hat es schon
verraten. Aber es
ist nicht das Einzige.
Die haben Ventrilo verwendet.
Und wenn
ihr dachtet,
Teamspeak sei schlecht,
dann habt ihr noch nie Ventrilo
verwendet.
Und wisst ihr,
was das Allerschlimmste war,
was manche auch verwendet haben damals?
Ähm...
Wie hieß das so?
What the fuck?
Geh weg.
Alter, was ist das da?
Gibt es da überhaupt noch
Screenshots von?
Ja, oh meine Güte.
Das war so schlecht, Alter.
Kennt das überhaupt noch jemand?
Das war
richtig mies.
Das hat auch hauptsächlich...
Das hat hauptsächlich so die englischsprachige
CS-Community damals verwendet.
Man hat
wirklich schon richtig viel Crap benutzt
damals. Aber eins muss man
echt sagen, eins hatte
die Software damals, was Software von heute
weniger hat. Die hatte halbwegs
gut durchdacht, also
gut optimierte Maus, Tastaturbedienung
und viele Optionen.
Heute, die Software ist ja darauf ausgelegt,
möglichst easy von irgendeinem Touchgerät
bedient werden zu können und kaum Optionen zu
haben. Guckt euch den aktuellen Firefox an,
mit einem älteren Firefox.
Egal, wir sind etwas
abgeschwiffen.
3 Monate,
Dankeschön für den IQ++
Subscription.
Okay, also
was haben wir? Discord installieren wir.
Brauchen wir zwar nicht, aber installieren wir. Teams
können wir auch installieren, okay.
TigerVNC. War TigerVNC das Ding,
nicht das Ding, die versucht haben
irgendwie X zu erweitern für
irgendwie 3D-Beschleunigung oder sowas?
Wire Desktop.
Was ist Wire Desktop?
Wire?
Was ist das?
Messenger?
Das sieht aus wie Skype mit einem
Elektron-Interface.
So als will ich es nicht verwenden.
Ich
glaub das.
Ich glaub das.
Ich glaub das will man nicht. Zoom!
Zoom.
Ist jemand bei euch
in der unglücklichen Situation
Zoom verwenden zu müssen?
Warum kann man kein Snapchat
installieren?
Ah ja stimmt, Snapchat gibt es ja für den Desktop gar nicht.
Ja? Oh ihr armen.
Zoom, alter!
Zoom ist so
das typische Programm,
was man rausgebracht hat und nicht mit dem Erfolg
gerechnet hat.
Stay01, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Okay, machen wir mal weiter.
Okay, Skype for Business ist aber auch ähnlich schlecht.
Okay, WebEx.
Also WebEx ist nur wirklich
2005.
Ja? WebEx haben wir früher auch verwendet.
Okay,
Teams und Discord. Ich will einfach nur wissen, ob das
aktuelle Version funktioniert.
Skype for Linux,
Stable, Slack. Okay, alles klar, next.
Development. Wollen wir davon irgendwas
installieren? Ja, Visual Studio Code.
Ich mag den Installer, das gefällt mir.
Dass man einfach schon auswählen kann,
was von dem ganzen Crap man haben will.
Oh, Moment.
Ich glaube, das ist das offizielle
Microsoft Visual Studio.
Und das ist...
Okay, also ein bisschen
Hilfetext wäre schon nicht verkehrt.
Ich gehe mal
davon aus, das ist das offizielle Microsoft Visual Studio
und das ist
die
Microsoft-fizierte Visual Studio Code Variante.
Aber ein bisschen was dahinter
schreiben hätte man schon können.
Ich weiß das auch nur, weil mir die
Auer-Repos, und wie spricht man die Dinger eigentlich aus?
Arch-User-Repos.
Irgendwie bekannt vorkommen. Die Auer-Repos.
Ob da der Bauer was mit zu tun hat?
So.
A-U-R-Repos.
Repos. Auer.
So.
Okay, aber next.
Was haben wir ansonsten noch zu...
Brackets. Brackets, hören wir das?
Brackets war richtig nice, der Editor, als er rausgekommen ist
mit diesem HTML-Live-Editing.
Ich glaube, hat bis heute noch keiner
so gut hingekriegt.
Notepad QQ.
Atomreihen.
Warum soll ich Atomreihen machen?
Oder Atom,
wie die coolen Leute sagen.
Kein Android-Studio.
Du kannst Android-Studio garantiert nachinstallieren.
Das ist eh sehr unvollständig, weil man mal ehrlich sagen muss,
PyCharm ist dabei.
Ach, es gibt eine PyCharm Community Edition?
Ernsthaft?
Da fühle ich mich jetzt aber benachteiligt
als .NET-Entwickler.
Warum gibt es eine PyCharm Community Edition
und keine Rider Community Edition?
Was soll das?
Doch, IntelliJ ist auch dabei.
Stimmt,
Neo Wimfield auch.
Weil MS-Leute Geld haben wollen.
Ja, aber das ist doch gar nicht von Microsoft.
Egal, weiter.
Also, Office aus Prinzip nichts.
Was? Money...
Money Dance.
Was zum Teufel ist Money Dance?
Das könnte irgendein...
was von Money Boy sein.
Money Dance.
Money Boy hat jetzt ja eine Kochshow.
Guckt jemand die Kochshow ab und zu von Money Boy?
Wie hieß das Ding nochmal?
Kitchen?
Ich hab's wieder vergessen.
Trap House Kitchen, genau.
Okay, das ist irgendeine Stonk-Software,
die ich nicht haben will.
Was will denn der Browser die ganze Zeit von mir?
Okay, wir installieren aus Prinzip keine Office-Software,
weil ihr kennt mich.
Office-Software braucht man nicht.
Multimedia...
brauchen wir jetzt hier auch nichts.
Aber es ist cool, dass man Kodi mit installieren kann.
Schon mal nice.
Inklusive Add-Ons.
Mal gucken.
Ob da auch der TV Head-End
Add-On dabei ist.
Will ich mal gleich ausprobieren.
OBS kannst du mit installieren.
Weil man kann das auch alles
nachinstallieren, das ist ja kein Ding.
Das hat...
Ich sag mal so, das sind im Prinzip die ganz normalen
User-Repos, die sie da hinzufügen wahrscheinlich.
Oder was auch immer.
Das kann man...
Mancharo kann ich exakt die gleichen Sachen
nachinstallieren.
Das ist einfach nur für
Convenience.
Chrome? Chromium?
Firefox? Okay.
FileZilla.
Ist das nicht irgendein
Torrent-Ding?
War das nicht Torrent?
Oder bring ich jetzt durcheinander?
Nein, Deluge.
Deluge, wie auch immer
man das ausspricht.
Porgers.
Das Torrent, ja.
Hexchat. Nice. IRC für die
Boomer unter uns.
Qt-Browser ist am Start.
Sebarro. Kaum kommt da Sebarro.
Brauchen wir den Qt-Browser, Leute?
Garantiert ist das Pacman.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was sie
für User-Repos verwenden.
Ich hab mich ja da mittlerweile auf J
da ein bisschen eingeschossen.
Pidgin.
Das war früher voll angesagt.
Zu Zeiten, wo man noch ICQ und so verwendet hat.
Weil das konnte mehrere Sachen.
Na gut. Weiter.
Gaming.
Minecraft-Launcher.
Sauerbraten ist am Start. Jawoll.
Das beste Game. Und wo ist SuperTuxCard?
Play on Linux. Sauerbraten.
Ludris.
Extreme
Tux Racer.
Xonotic.
Xonotic kenn ich nicht.
Was ist Xonotic?
Die meisten Open Source Games
sehen halt echt aus wie von 1998.
Oder so.
Okay, das ging zu eins auf Quake.
Quake gemachtes.
Alter, der Browser nervt mich jetzt schon.
Okay, next.
Utilities. Was brauchen wir?
Wireshark. Klar, Wireshark braucht man immer.
Putti.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Das letzte, was ich über Unternehmensinstallieren
muss, ist glaube ich Putti, oder?
Ich bin ja begeistert,
dass es das überhaupt gibt.
Das System-D-Manager.
Okta.
Autopie.
OpenVM-Tools. Die müssen wir auf jeden Fall installieren.
Dass das hier Fullscreen geht.
Übrigens, was ich auch gut finde,
dass sie in ihrem Live-ISO
die VM-Tools drin haben, dass das hier gleich
auf Fullscreen geht.
Firewall-Geschissen.
Albert kann man installieren.
ZSH.
VirtualBox.
USB?
Ah.
Das sind jetzt Gruppen, oder was?
Davon will ich nichts installieren.
Davon will ich auch nichts installieren.
Ich verwende immer Tuna als File-Manager.
Den gibt es hier gar nicht.
Was taugt denn davon? Nemo? Keine Ahnung.
Brauchen wir alles nicht. Alles weglassen.
Der von KDE.
Das ist der, oder?
Oder ist Nemo?
Gar nicht. Endlich ist es egal. Ich verwende das eh nicht.
ZSH, please.
Das Problem an ZSH ist,
ohne
Konfig sagt es, finde ich.
Und ich will jetzt hier nicht irgendeine komische
fette Default-Config
drauf packen.
Terminals. Gnome-Terminal.
Ja, muss.
TMAX muss auch.
USB.
Etcher kannst du auch gleich mit drauf machen.
Ist eigentlich eine coole Sache. ZSH.
Machen wir ZSH.
Nur die echten Hackermans nennen es ZSH.
Ruby.
Fun.
Password-Manager.
Was?
Ich finde das eigentlich ganz nice, dass sie das so gemacht haben.
Nicht, dass man das bräuchte.
Weil jeder,
der mal 5 Minuten da unter Achtelungs was gemacht hat,
kann das über User-Depots nachinstallieren.
Aber warum nicht?
Okay, Europe, Berlin. Alles klar.
System-Language.
Ich möchte eigentlich noch mein Keyboard-Layout.
Ach, das kommt jetzt gleich.
Mein Keyboard-Layout einschätzen.
Guck mal hier!
Der ist richtig...
geht gut.
Wenn du ein Alias anlegen, dann kannst du das machen.
Ist eigentlich eine richtig gute Idee.
Git...
Das muss ich mal aufschreiben.
Das ist ein richtig nice Ding.
Wenn ich mal irgendwie...
Ich mach ein gitgut-Alias-Script oder so.
Ich mach irgendwie ein Script, was unter gitgut
irgendwas halbwegs Sinnvolles macht.
Und dann mach ich das auf GitHub.
Easy 500 Sterne.
Aber was ich hier auch schon mal ganz gut finde,
dass die so schlau sind und sagen,
okay, du willst als Sprache Englisch,
aber als Unit,
Einheiten, Currency und so,
willst du keine Freedom Units,
sondern ordentliche Einheiten,
wie es in Deutschland gibt.
Hast du WLAN-Steckdosen,
die man mit einem Pi steuern kann?
Eine?
30 oder so.
Allerdings kannst du die jetzt nicht unbedingt
nur mit einem Pi steuern,
sondern mit jedem x-beliebigen Ding,
was im WLAN hängt.
Was hältst du von der Opsi-Software-Verwaltung?
Kenne ich nicht.
Ob sie klingt so ein bisschen nach
irgendwas von einer deutschen Firma,
was die Marketingabteilung,
beziehungsweise dort die Salesleute
verkauft haben,
und ihr jetzt an der Backe habt
und du das irgendwie ausbaden musst.
Achso, kenne ich nicht, ne.
Open System Integration.
Ne, kenne ich nicht.
Sagt mir gar nichts.
Was für einen Monster-Router hast du?
Ich hab gar keinen Monster-Router.
Ich hab einen Mikrotik-Hex-PO,
und für VoIP und Gedöns
die billigste Fritzbox aller Zeiten.
Und ganz vorne
halt das Unity-Media-Ding.
Welche Steckdosen verwendest du da?
Das ist eine gute Frage
und ich würde dir das auch zeigen.
Die Sache ist nur die,
dass die Steckdosen,
die ich verwende,
mit der aktuellen Firmware
nicht mehr empfehlenswert sind.
Also ich hab ein paar,
ich hab ein paar Steckdosenleisten
von CoGeek, heißt der Herr,
im Prinzip sind das alles
Thuja-Steckdosenleisten.
Ich hab dann diesen Vierer-Pack,
den wir im Stream mal geflasht haben.
Das Problem ist,
ich kauf mir diese Dinger immer nur,
wenn es gerade eine
Lücke in der Firmware gibt
oder bekannt ist, ob man da Custom-Firmware
drauf machen kann.
Und ich kann dir keine mehr empfehlen,
weil die meisten aktuell nicht mehr
geflasht werden können mit Custom-Firmware.
Und bei diesen
Steckdosenleisten und Steckdosen
kann man eigentlich Custom-Firmware haben,
bei diesen normalen Thuja-Steckdosenleisten,
weil ansonsten kannst du die nur über
die China-App, äh über die China-Cloud
mit der offiziellen China-App steuern.
Und das ist natürlich totaler Müll.
Man will die ja übers eigene WLAN steuern können,
über ein Webinterface oder die
Heimautomatisierung oder sowas, ja.
Aber ich kann das mal zeigen, zum Beispiel,
äh, tja, ähm,
haben wir irgendwie
eine IP von einer Steckdosenleiste?
Ich weiß jetzt gerade keine.
Ah, bam, da ist eine Steckdosenleiste, zum Beispiel.
Die kann ich steuern hier übers WLAN.
Da muss ich aber aufpassen,
ich glaube, das ist die,
wo ich gerade mein ganzes Zeug hier für den Stream auch
dran hab, die sollte ich nicht an- und ausschalten.
Hast du ein eigenes WLAN für deine
Steckdosenleisten? Ja. Achso!
Nee. Ich hab nen
IoT-WLAN. Ich hab nen extra
da sind auch die ganzen China-Kameras drin.
Trotz Custom-Firmware.
Hä, was willst du probieren?
Hab ich was übersehen? Ha!
Ich bin dafür, dass man per Channel-Post
Oh, wirklich?
Ruby!
Das ist ne gute Idee,
das schreib ich mir auf.
Pssst, der scheiß Knob.
Der Typ hat echt
Eindruck hinterlassen, wenn der wüsste,
dass ich das jetzt hier
300 Leuten erzählt hab.
Okay, also wir installieren den Kram
jetzt erstmal weiter. Next. Keyboard,
Keyboard soll Cherokee,
natürlich, was sonst?
Ist das nicht ein Auto?
Ist das nicht irgend so ein fettes Auto?
Äh, ihr wisst, ich hab von Autos keinen Plan.
Äh, No-Dead-Keys?
Bestimmt im Chat der
Gnome-Typ. Oh, das glaub ich nicht.
No-Dead-Keys?
Ja, ich weiß, dass das ein Indianerstamm
ist. Deswegen, ja.
Ich brauch unbedingt das
Indianer-Tastatur-Layout.
Replace
Partition, Erase Disk, jawoll.
Swap. Wir brauchen
Swap. Wir haben 8G RAM, das reicht.
MBR.
Okay, das kommt wahrscheinlich drauf an.
BIOS, kommt wahrscheinlich drauf an, was wir gebootet haben, okay.
Ist aber auch egal.
40G für Heftor Linux.
Alles klar. Next.
Next. User.
What's your name?
Qt Chat. Oh, ne.
So.
Alles klar. Name of this
Computer. Qt Chat
Forever Virtual Platform, genau so muss
es heißen. Genau so muss es
heißen. Das ist ein bisschen lang vielleicht.
Eleven Head.
Passwort.
123456.
Log in automatically.
Ja.
Jawoll. Gleiches Passwort für
Root.
Vielleicht sollte man das Root-Account nennen, nicht Administrator.
Die meisten Leute können mit
Administrator oder Linux nichts anfangen.
Was ist eigentlich Swap?
Das ist das, was unter Windows Auslagerungsdatei
ist.
Also wenn der RAM voll ist,
wo man dann quasi die Festplatte
als RAM verwenden kann oder halt
irgendwas anderes als RAM.
Man könnte natürlich auch,
was jetzt natürlich schon ziemlich sinnlos ist, aber man könnte
auch eine RAM-Disk
erstellen und auf der RAM-Disk
ein Swap-File anlegen
und dann das Swap-File als Swap
mounten.
Das würde funktionieren.
Was aber reichlich sinnlos
ist. Hast du dir mal
PingFS angeguckt? Nein.
Ping?
Stores your data in ICMP...
Oh, was ist das?
True Cloud Storage
PingFS. Filesystem
where data is stored only in
the Internet etc.
Das heißt, der pingt sich
unendlich lang oder was?
Das heißt, der pingt einfach
unendlich lang und
dadurch ist... also der pingt halt
jegliche Daten
immer unendlich lang hin und her
oder was? Das ist geil.
Das müssen wir ausprobieren.
Ich gehe gleich mal auf meine To-Do-List.
PingFS, beste.
Next Level, Big Brain, ja.
Okay, also, next.
Also,
Summary. Wir wollen uns auf Europe setzen.
Deutsch, Englisch, Tastatur,
Past, Erase,
eine new MS-DOS Partition Table.
Natürlich, Bill Gates wird sich
freuen. Install.
Oh.
Was?
Die haben nicht wirklich so einen Wizard gemacht, oder?
Wo du jetzt irgendwelche
komischen...
Naja, ich will es nicht mal 3D-Renders nennen,
solche irgendwie so komischen
Dinger
hast.
Es gibt halt nur zwei Bilder, ne?
Mehr als zwei Bilder gibt's
erstmal nicht.
Zwei Bilder müssen reichen
dafür. Und was ist das hier für
komisches
Ninja-Zeug daneben dran?
Das könnte... Leute, das daneben
dran könnte irgendein Naruto-Cosplay sein
oder so.
Ich hab nie großartig Naruto geguckt.
Ich kenn bloß so ein paar Clips auf YouTube.
Und, ähm, das ist ja bei
Naruto wohl irgendwie normal, dass die
50 Augen haben und
90 Schwänze und
500 Finger und sowas und sich dann gegenseitig
bashen. Also, es könnte wirklich
irgendwie so... Ja, oder irgendwie
irgendwelche komischen
Sandkugeln werden und sowas, ja.
Dann kann das auch so sein.
Gachi-Eifer.
Stop talking.
Ja, wie stimmt das etwa nicht?
Ich kenn nur ein paar Ausschnitte auf YouTube.
Und da übertreiben
sie es halt mit Fähigkeiten auch wieder extrem.
Scheiße, es ist so... Ich glaub,
es ist eher so eine... Es ist bestimmt
eine Serie, wo die halt angefangen
haben, ohne sich
darüber Gedanken zu machen.
Korrigiert mich, wenn ich falsch liege. Ich hab keine
Ahnung. Aber wo sie sich am Anfang keine
Gedanken drüber gemacht haben, dass das irgendwie
äh, keine Ahnung, 15 Jahre
läuft und am Ende irgendwie
nen, keine Ahnung,
nen Furz zwei Planeten
zerstört. Und deswegen
mussten sie, ähm,
sich sehr merkwürdige
Erklärungen überlegen am Ende, warum die Leute so
stark sind. Das ist das, was
mir auch an Dragon Ball auf den Keks geht.
Das ist exakt genauso.
Ja, das hab ich,
das hab ich auch gelesen, dass das jetzt fertig
ist, ja. Das hab ich auch mitbekommen.
One Piece hab ich gar nicht mehr
verfolgt. Ich hab früher ab und zu
mal ein bisschen geguckt. Ihr wisst ja, ich bin nicht
kein allzu großer Anime-Gucker.
Ein paar hab ich geguckt, aber nicht so wahnsinnig
viele. One Piece hab ich früher
ab und zu ein bisschen geguckt. Und
ich hab letztens mal wieder,
als ich auf, auf einer
selbstverständlich furchtbar legalen
Streaming-Seite gewesen bin, in eine
aktuelle Folge reingeguckt.
Und, und irgendwie
Oh, ist der jetzt fertig?
Und, what?
What is?
What, what is happening?
Ähm. Ah, installiert.
Ja, zumindest, ich hab letztens
in irgendeiner halbwegs aktuellen Folge
oder so mal wieder reingeguckt.
Irgendwie sehen jetzt alle ganz anders
aus.
Und haben
absolut, also ich
mein, das waren schon immer abgedrehte Fähigkeiten,
aber jetzt komplett abgedrehte
Dinger, so mit, so mit, so mit,
so mit, ähm,
äh, Dampfantrieb
und sowas. The fuck?
Das ist, keine Ahnung mehr.
Ich hab da nicht weitergeguckt.
Ne, ich weiß, was das war. Wenn man scrollt,
wenn man scrollt mit der Maus, dann
blendet, dann switcht er die Desktops.
Okay, aber die zwei, also ich mein, immerhin
haben sie zwei stylische Installer-
Bilder, ja? Ist ja schon mal was.
Wir haben übrigens grad
256 Zuschauer.
Excellent.
Kann man Linux in PingFS
installieren? Ich weiß nicht genau, wie
PingFS funktioniert, aber ich vermute mal nicht,
weil PingFS, was ist, was
darauf aufsetzt, dass schon was da ist?
Was ist denn die Mod-Taste?
Was? Versteh nicht,
was du meinst. Was denn die Mod-Taste
ist? Die Mod-Taste?
Mod-Check?
Achso, ne, das ist die Windows-Taste. Ich weiß, was
du meinst. War ein
schlechter G-Bait-Versuch von mir.
Äh, das ist die Windows-Taste.
Du kannst das ummappen,
aber in der Regel ist das die Windows-Taste.
Auch Super genannt manchmal.
Oder war Super alt?
Habt ihr mich verwirrt,
Leute? Ne, ich glaub Super und Mod ist...
Also Mod ist im Prinzip
das, was du konfiguriert hast,
als Mod-Taste und normalerweise
ist es eben Super, also die Windows-Taste.
Standardmäßig.
Man kann das beispielsweise unter E3 remappen,
dass man
ähm, zum Beispiel
Alt verwendet, anstatt Windows-Taste.
Aber
in der Regel kann es von ausgehend
ist die Windows-Taste gemeint.
Installing 4 Packages.
Excellent.
Alt ist Mod 1. Ja, stimmt.
Ja, hast recht.
Und was ist...
Ganz, ganz doofe Frage.
Wow.
Das ist aber hier mal Next Level.
Was ist eigentlich
das für eine Taste?
Hier während es installiert, hat irgendjemand
eine Ahnung für die...
Frage ich mich jetzt gerade, wo ich auf die Tastatur gucke.
Die Daseinsberechtigung von...
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Logitech G513.
Die Daseinsberechtigung von dieser Taste.
Von der da.
Also ich weiß, dass die Menüs aufmacht,
aber wozu braucht man das?
Warum ist die auf jeder Tastatur drauf?
Könnte man die nicht sinnvoller verwenden?
Könnte man nicht zum Beispiel
eine extra breite Control-Taste
machen, dass man besser crouchen kann in Games?
Fallback für defekte Maus.
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich hatte mehr
defekte Tastaturen als defekte Mäuse bisher.
Vor 60 Jahren. Okay, wirkt
top aktuell, dass man die braucht.
Ja. Rechtes Control
für Crouch. Klar, wenn du einen 15 cm
langen Daumen hast, dann schon.
Kobold-Taste.
Ja, Screen-Log ist auch richtig
sinnlos. Braucht auch keiner mehr.
Das ganze Zeug braucht keiner mehr.
Okay, das brauchst du unter Windows noch, um
Screenshots zu machen. Aber ansonsten...
Das brauchst du nicht mehr.
Damit konntest du früher pausen beim Booten.
Ähm...
Was das
macht, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Und ich bin ja
übrigens Fan von Numplog.
Gibt ja viele mittlerweile, die
sagen, Numplog ist useless und die kaufen sich eine
kurze Variante von einer Tastatur ohne Numplog.
Aber ich mag Numplog.
Weiß nicht, wie es mit euch aussieht, Chat.
Ob ihr eher Numplog
oder Anti-Numplog
seid. Aber ich, ich
kann ohne Numplog nicht.
Numplog muss Numplog, ja.
Vor allem, wisst ihr, was die
Taste ist beim Numplog, die ich ja meist
verwende? Von allen denen hier.
Also, außer die Numplog-An- und
Aus-Taste, weil es meistens nicht an ist.
Ähm, aber die meist benutzte Taste
ist Enter. Ja.
Ist echt so. Die meist benutzte
Numplog-Taste ist Enter bei mir.
SexyRexy
Exquisite Subscription. Dankeschön.
IQ++
Numplog ist useless.
Nein, Numplog ist das Beste.
Frag mal eine Kassiererin, ob der Numplog
useless ist. Du nutzt
Sternchen
und Slash. Okay.
Haben wir es heute eigentlich nochmal mit
installieren? Die große
Leertaste ist sinnlos.
Ja, da kann...
Ja, ja, teilweise schon.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
ich bin ja jemand, der gerne in... Warum ist
die Musik gerade so laut?
Ähm...
Ich bin ja jemand, der darauf schwört,
Jump auf Space zu haben.
Obwohl ja die richtig coolen Pros in
Spielen, wo gesprungen wird, mittlerweile
den Jump alle auf Mausrad haben.
Aber ich bin
nicht so cool. Ich hab Jump nicht auf Mausrad.
All done.
Und da finde ich es ganz gut, wenn man
easy mit dem Daumen irgendwo in die Mitte
haut und kommt auf die Leertaste.
Okay. All done.
Restart now. Done. Bam.
Jump auf Recht? Echt?
Das glaube ich dir nicht.
Da sind wir. Bam.
Das ging schnell.
Heftor Edition
Welcome App.
Twitch.
Die machen es richtig.
Hier kannst du dem Heftor Entwickler
einfach mal auf Twitch zugucken.
Sagenhafte zwei Follower hat er.
Excellent.
Choose Password for Keyring.
Continue.
Excellent. Details.
Es nervt schon mal rum mit Updates,
was sehr gut ist. Also,
das Dark Theme gefällt mir inklusive dem Hintergrund.
Was ich nicht ganz so gelungen finde,
ist der Kontrast
der Schrift.
Weil,
einen dunkel-grau-blauen Hintergrund
und eine etwas hellere,
dunkle, grau-blaue Schrift ist vielleicht
ein bisschen zu viel des Guten.
Aber hier kann man updaten.
Wie updatet man denn?
Da.
Ups.
Habe ich die vertippt?
Wie kann man sich bei 123456
vertippen?
Geht anscheinend.
Ist anscheinend möglich. So, dann gibt es noch
einen von denen.
Restart is required.
Ist jetzt kaputt.
Jetzt.
YouTube.
YouTube ist ja auch am Start.
Brad Heffernan.
350 Subs.
Github.
Heftors.
Und Donate in PayPal kann man auch.
Excellent. Das sollten mehrere Distros machen
in der Richtung. Ein bisschen Eigenwerbung ist nicht
verkehrt. Gerade in der heutigen Zeit,
wenn Social Media Präsenz alles ist,
um irgendwie bekannt zu werden, ist das sicherlich
nicht verkehrt.
Okay, kann ich jetzt hier direkt drüber restarten?
Wie kann ich hier überhaupt
restarten?
Jetzt wird es komplex.
Wie restarte ich? Da drüber?
Ne.
Huh. Ich meine, ich kann Terminal
aufmachen und rebooten, aber das ist wahrscheinlich
nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Ah, da oben.
Da oben.
Da oben. Aber das ist halt auch
kontrastmäßig fragwürdig.
Hier oben.
Restart.
Das North Theme. Ich glaube, das habe ich sogar mal
eine Weile verwendet.
Das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor, als du das
gerade schreibst.
Ne, habe ich nicht.
Ich verwende eigentlich fast überall
irgendeine Base 16
Tomorrow Night
Variante.
Okay, zweimal installiert.
Qt Browser hat
WIM-artige Tastenkombination. Das ist
doch gut.
Hier ist der Qt Browser. Ne.
Ha. She baited.
Es ist QBitTorrent.
Es ist nicht der Qt Browser.
Hat das Ding ein Startmenü oder sowas?
Hat das Ding in irgendeiner Art und Weise ein Startmenü?
Da oben vielleicht?
Ah.
Der hat sich versteckt hinter dem...
Da müssen wir mal kurz
ausblenden.
Ah.
Leute, das hat...
Das Nvidia-Ding hat meine Tastatur gefressen.
Meine Maus geht nicht mehr.
Das Nvidia-Ding hat
meine Maus gefressen.
Okay, okay.
Jetzt brauchen wir Big Brain.
Jetzt brauchen wir Big Brain. Was können wir jetzt machen?
Ne, ne.
Kontextmenü bringt mir nichts.
Ich kriege da keinen Fokus drauf.
Okay, was können wir jetzt machen?
Alter, 4 bringt nichts.
Okay, was machen wir jetzt, Leute?
Big Brain, Big Brain. Was machen wir jetzt?
Task Manager.
Task Manager geht nicht.
Ne, ne. Es geht in Windows D, in Windows R geht alles nicht.
Okay, okay.
Tastatur rein, Maus rein, raus.
Erstmal Tastatur rein, raus.
Vielleicht reicht das ja schon.
Hopp.
Okay, das sagt jetzt natürlich mal richtig.
Ich muss mal kurz hinter den Rechner.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich die Maus...
Ich mach einfach eine zweite...
Exquisite Idee.
Ich mach jetzt einfach eine zweite Maus dran.
Geht nicht.
Okay, jetzt natürlich doof.
Soll ich die andere Maus mal rein und raus?
Und jetzt? Ne, ne.
Ja, ja, kommt. Das geht, aber dann...
Jetzt hab ich echt ein Problem, ne?
Chat, da sind wir wieder.
Bam!
Wir sind wieder am Start, Leute.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Hackerman am Start.
Was hab ich gemacht? Ich hab gesagt Switch User.
Switch User und bin dann wieder raus.
Okay, jetzt mach ich das mal aus.
Ähm...
Off, off.
Und jetzt geht's wieder.
Alles klar.
So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ich hab das Startmenü gesucht. Da oben, genau.
Okay, das ist so ein ganz normales XFCE Startmenü.
Was haben wir da? Der Qt Browser.
Da ist er.
Oh!
Sieht ja schon mal...
Okay, man kann wenigstens ordentlich resizen hier.
Qt Session Warning.
Okay, es sind Wim...
Also, es sind Wim-Shortcuts, habt ihr gesagt.
Also, das heißt...
Ich geh jetzt mal, keine Ahnung, auf YouTube.
Oh, ne, das ist...
Insert Mode!
What the fuck?
Okay, das heißt auch, ich kann Escape drücken.
Und dann kann ich Doppelpunkt machen.
Und dann sagen wir New Tab.
Tab.
Okay, das ist... Warum nicht?
Warum nicht? Ja.
Okay, ähm...
Ich suche mich mal auf YouTube.
Ah, guck mal jetzt...
Boah, das ist ja
Big Brain Logik.
Jetzt kann ich...
Äh, äh, äh, GT?
Ne, fuck, was ist Back in Wim?
Äh, R.
Ne, R ist Reload in dem Fall.
Ähm...
Wie komm ich in die Seite zurück?
Ja, da wird schon kompliziert.
Back.
Control. Undo.
Ne.
Ach Quatsch. Moment.
R war Replace. Wie komm ich jetzt auf R gerade?
Großes Redo, genau.
Control O.
Ne.
Hm.
Zumindest, man kann navigieren.
Guckt mal.
Wenn ich jetzt... Mal angenommen, ich benutze die Maus jetzt nicht.
Kann ich F drücken. Und jetzt mach ich GL.
Dann klickt er den ersten Link für mich an.
F.
Mal gucken, ob wir so YouTube navigiert kriegen, ey.
Haha.
Oh, das ist ja verboten.
Hab ich ja letztens beim Nummernschild gelernt.
So.
F.
Okay, wie kann ich jetzt agreeen?
Wie agree ich jetzt hier?
LFK?
Nein.
Tja.
Wo wir wieder mal an meinem Punkt sind.
Man kann Browser nur gescheit mit einer Tastatur, äh, mit einer Maus bedienen.
KK.
Ne. Hm.
SJ?
Tja.
Also, ich bleib dabei.
Das ist ja auch das, was ich immer drauf sage,
wenn die Leute mir erzählen,
ja, aber in meinem Vim, da bin ich
immer mit meinen Fingern auf der Home-Row.
Und ich kann immer, ähm,
superschnell navigieren in meinem Vim.
Und dann ist meine erste Frage, ist ja und?
Was machst du, wenn du mal
im Browser was nachgucken musst?
Ja, und dann kommen sie an mit,
ja, ich hab irgendein Vim-Add-On oder
sonst was.
Das Problem ist aber, dass du mit, äh,
Tastatur-Bedienung-Only
halt in den Browser,
ehrlich gesagt, Kacke verdienen, äh,
bedienen kannst.
Als Ergänzung ist es ganz cool, ja.
Zum Beispiel ist es für mich jetzt viel einfacher,
DH zu tippen oder sowas.
Oder, oder, hier SA für Startseite.
Guck, aber, das Popup,
LHK, LHK ist
no thanks. Okay, das hat jetzt funktioniert.
Ottes Pianogrill.
So, äh,
so, jetzt Popup hat sich erledigt.
Review
genau will ich jetzt anklicken. FA.
F. I agree.
Was ist I agree?
LGL. Nee.
LAL.
Auch nicht.
Okay, es ist, es, es geht halt nicht.
Man kann halt, man kann halt einfach keinen Browser
Was ist das?
Das ist broken.
Guck mal, ich kann den Browser nicht zumachen.
Okay, das geht ja schon mal gut los.
Das geht ja schon mal gut los.
Ist dieser, äh, ist dieser Dialog
dann überhaupt
accessible?
Was machen blinde User bei diesem Dialog?
Ich glaube, YouTube ist nicht optimiert
für blinde Benutzer.
So kacke ist es. Ich glaube, das juckt
YouTube nicht.
Was ich aber nicht verstehe, ehrlich gesagt,
das sollte sie nämlich jucken, weil YouTube
eine super Plattform ist, denke ich mal, auch für
sehbehinderte Blinde zu konsumieren. Gibt ja auch viele Sachen,
die man sich einfach anhören kann.
Und
YouTube tut, und generell Google tut
immer so wahnsinnig exclusive
und make a change und sonst was.
Da könnten sie ihre Seiten aber zumindest
mal für sehbehinderte optimieren.
Äh, kurze
Zwischenfrage, welches Betriebssystem
empfiehlst du für einen NAS-Server?
Auf welcher Hardware denn?
So, kann ich jetzt Qt, ah, jetzt darf ich den Qt-Browser
zumachen, aber sonst, fuck.
Okay, das buggt.
Ah, das geht, ah, Moment, das geht nach einer Zeit
weg. Jetzt, ups.
Jetzt verstehe ich das.
Geht nach einer Zeit weg.
Aber, aber,
ja, aber das ist,
das ist Usability
kompletter Müll. Ich mein,
ich mach doch, guck mal, wenn ich,
Leute, wenn ich das Fenster zumach, dann
ziel ich doch nicht mit der Maustaste
erst auf dieses kleine Furzding da oben.
Da schmeiß ich den Mausteig in die rechte
obere Ecke und klick druff.
Ne, ich hab noch nie ein anderes Tastatur-Layout ausprobiert.
Normale Rechte, dann nehm Ubuntu-Server.
Ich mag Ubuntu-Server.
Äh, Sebastian Keller, ich glaub, das hab ich sogar schon
mal verwendet. Da kann man, also
falls das das ist, oder es gibt bestimmt noch andere,
da kann man Vim verwenden, wenn man
im Textfeld was editiert und so. Das ist tatsächlich
cool, ja. Integriertes Aim-Training.
Ja, im Prinzip ist das
sowas. Aber das ist nervig.
Alter, das, das, das
nervt, das geht mir jetzt schon, vor allem geht's
jetzt nicht mehr weg, das, das geht mir
jetzt schon extrem auf den Keks.
Da weiß ich jetzt schon,
dass ich das nicht benutzen kann.
Da klicke ich ja jedes Mal auf dieses
komische Menü. Im Zweifelsfall mach ich sogar aus Versehen
Restart, ohne, der
ohne Nachfrage Restart, nur weil ich das Fenster zumachen
will. Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das ist, das ist, finde ich, nicht so gut gemacht.
Hallo, dumme Frage,
was meinst du, was als
Einstiegsgehalt zum FISI okay ist?
Ja, kommt auf die Region an.
Das kommt wirklich ganz extrem
auf die Region an. Das ist doch
Linux geht sicher irgendwie mit Sicherheit, aber
ich installiere ja sowas hier gerade, da ich nicht selbst
rumfuddeln muss. By the way,
Desktop geht nicht mehr.
RIP. Broken.
Reboot. Hat nicht funktioniert.
Shutdown. Ich bin ja immer begeistert,
wie einfach ich es schaffe,
diese ganzen Distributionen zu zerstören.
Dabei mach ich ja gar nichts.
Ah, jetzt hat er es wieder gecheckt, okay.
Alles klar, weiter. Okay,
was haben wir sonst noch drauf? Also, Startmenü.
Probier doch mal Gentoo.
Ich bin ja glücklich mit meinem, was ich hab.
So, den ganzen üblichen Krempel.
Office, brauchen wir nicht.
Cute Capture Utility.
Okay.
Startet schon mal nicht, hat keinen Bock.
Rechtsklick auf dem Desktop geht übrigens nicht.
Warum geht
Rechtsklick auf dem Desktop? Was ist das hier unten?
Sublime Text 3
Dev. Hä? Habe ich das
vorhin ausgewählt? Nee, oder?
Ich habe doch vorhin keinen Sublime Text
ausgewählt. Oh.
Ah, okay, das verschiebt keine Icons auf den Desktop.
Das löscht die Dinger. Okay, das
damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet.
Aber das geht
aufs Desktop schieben. What?
Okay, das ist
ziemlich inkonsistent.
Ich kann aus dem Startmenü was auf den Desktop schieben,
aber aus der Leiste? Auf dem Desktop
löscht das. Hm.
Ist das ein Audio
Visualizer? Das ist eine gute Frage.
Machen wir mal VLC irgendwas an.
VLC.
Ja, wir brauchen
erstmal was zum Playbacken.
Was
playbacken wir denn mal? Ein Video
von mir. Erstmal YouTube DL.
Erstmal YouTube DL.
So, Gnome, Terminal.
Zack.
Das ist unter
Mac auch so... Echt, nochmal?
Das ist so... Ah, Farbschema
gefällt mir nicht wirklich gut.
Okay.
Ah, okay.
YouTube DL, das Allerwichtigste,
was wir jetzt erstmal runterladen müssen.
YouTube DL ist schon an mich installiert.
Excellent, excellent, excellent.
Okay, dann lade ich jetzt nämlich ein eigenes Video
von mir runter. Da kann sich
keiner Copyright-mäßig aufregen.
So. Zack.
Paste.
YouTube DL.
Da.
So, und dann spielen wir das ab. Wo ist mein
File Manager? Tuna!
Den will ich doch eigentlich haben. Was hatten wir denn noch
zusätzlich installiert?
Ähm. Tja.
Dolphin, oder?
Der sieht überhaupt nicht passend aus
hier drinnen. Aber klar, ich meine,
das ist ein KDE
Ding in irgendeinem GTK, der
Desktop. Das sieht nicht wirklich passend aus.
Games.
Xtreme Tox Racer.
Jawoll. Oh, diese High-Quality
Open-Source-Games wieder.
X-Sandmenschen, genau.
Das Sandmenschen, ja.
Tox Racer Classic
Canadian Cup.
Bunny Hill. Oh!
Massive!
Also, also,
es ist ja,
da ist ja RTX.
Ups. Das habe ich irgendwie ausgemacht.
Jetzt wollte ich es gar nicht ausmachen.
Moment, nochmal.
Okay, Bunny.
Bunny.
Ach, Select Your Player Name ist das.
Racer.
Tox, Trixi,
Boris, Samuel.
Sieht ja eins schlimmer aus
als das andere, Alter.
Konfiguration.
Gibt es da noch mehr?
Exquisite Graphics. Level of Detail.
Jawoll. Gibt es mir.
Tolle Pulle.
Level of Detail.
A4 ist Maximum.
Enter.
Continue.
Race.
Kann man springen oder so?
High-Quality Open-Source-Games.
Übrigens, der springt,
der springt erst, wenn man die Leertaste loslässt.
Das ist total,
total merkwürdig.
Normalerweise springt man,
wenn man die Leertaste drückt.
Wenn man die Leertaste loslässt,
ganz merkwürdig, Alter.
Vor allem auch wie hoch.
Was springt beim Loslassen ist normal bei SSX.
Was ist SSX?
Failed.
Was?
Warum habe ich Failed?
Ha, Sauerei.
Ach so, das ist, dass man quasi so,
so, so,
je nachdem, wie lang man das gedrückt hat,
umso, um,
umso mehr springt man quasi.
Umso mehr springt man quasi.
Kann man bremsen, irgendwie?
Oh, guck mal, ich kann bremsen.
Excellent.
High-Quality 2D-Fische.
Hier, guckt euch mal den Fisch an.
Okay, nee, ich muss wieder raus.
Was Sauerbraten, please.
Sauerbraten könnten wahrscheinlich
sogar ein paar Leute kennen.
Sauerbraten ist quasi Quake,
Quake 3, nicht ganz so Quake 3-ig,
ähm, remaked.
Mr. Fixit, excellent.
Äh.
Meine Maus geht nicht.
Ja, ich würd's, ich würd's ja gerne, gerne spielen,
aber, geht nicht.
Kann nix machen.
Okay. Gibt's so ne Art Taskmanager,
um den Kram zu killen?
Oder muss ich X-Kill machen?
Bam.
Schreckt.
Okay.
So, jetzt können wir mal gucken, ob das in der Mitte...
Der Knopf geht nicht.
Ah, Moment, der Knopf geht
doch, das war...
Das in der Mitte ist...
Hat mit dem laufenden Audio...
Mit dem laufenden Video in der Mitte
nix zu tun.
Das ist, glaub ich, einfach nur Show.
Ja, du bist im Video, Mr. Army.
Genau.
Irgendwo da warst du grade, ja.
Okay, das hat damit nix zu tun.
Übrigens, das ist wirklich die Sache, wo sich Windows
was von abschneiden könnte.
Die Linux-Suche funktioniert in der Regel deutlich besser
als die Windows-Suche.
Das wirkt wieder so un...
Ha, wie soll ich sagen, so...
Gesamm...
Gesteckt, aber nicht richtig gepolished.
Schwer zu sagen.
So, hier oben haben wir dann unseren VLC.
Den kann man minimieren, maximieren, alles klar, okay.
Quit.
Muted.
Ah, okay. Audio-Mixer.
So ein übliches...
PR-Panel oder sowas.
Wie nen Manjaro auf Wish.
Es ist schon...
Es ist schon ganz gut gemacht, aber...
Übrigens...
What the fuck?
Ich kann von links unten nach...
Ich kann von rechts unten nach links oben
ohne Probleme
auf dem Desktop
dieses Ding ziehen, ja.
Aber von links oben...
Seht ihr?
Ach, Moment.
Das ist nur, wenn ich hier drauf klicke.
Das hier ist doch irgendein Bedienelement.
Und wenn ich hier drauf klicke,
krieg ich auch ein Rechtsklick-Menü, hier nicht.
Okay, was macht das in der Mitte?
Ja, das ist das Musik-Overlay.
Ich hab ja grad versucht, das Musik-Overlay anzubekommen.
Ich weiß aber nicht wie.
Open File.
Ah.
So, ich hab jetzt ein Video vor mir laufen.
Ich hab's minimiert, aber da läuft nix.
So, Musik ist aus.
Breitbandausbau in Deutschland.
Und ich hab jetzt zweieinhalb Jahre gewartet,
seitdem ich das letzte Video gemacht habe.
Und ich habe heute so ein bisschen...
Interessiert's nicht.
Soll ich das Video machen oder soll ich das Video nicht machen?
Weil ich muss sagen...
Ich mach mal ab.
Wahrscheinlich nur Spotify.
Das ist irgendwie...
Ich weiß nicht.
What the f...
Ist der VLC jetzt gecrashed?
Hallo?
VLC? Please?
Okay, du willst da Crap, alter.
Okay, das Settings-Menü ist schon mal besser als das Windows-Settings-Menü.
Das ist aber auch kein...
Heftor GUI.
Oh, was ist das?
Warum soll ich das machen?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich hab's jetzt einfach mal gemacht.
Moment.
Darf man sowas mit ausliefern?
So cool...
Das darf man bestimmt nicht mit ausliefern.
Das ist bestimmt tos, wenn man das mit ausliefert.
Direkt Nintendo vor der Haustür und klopft an.
Wobei, das könnte sogar wirklich erlaubt sein.
Also wenn das ein Custom...
Wenn das ein Custom-Fanart ist,
dann könnte das durchaus erlaubt sein, ja.
Okay, haben ganz schicke Hintergründe.
Und da ist wieder dieses komische Ding.
Sieht aus wie aus Wolfenstein.
Die Discord ist dabei, nix im Trash.
BitTorrent weg.
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, bis jetzt hat's mich nicht so wahnsinnig überzeugt.
Ist das ASCII-Quarium drauf?
Gute Frage.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber nachdem's ein vollwertiges Arch ist,
können wir das ASCII-Quarium nachinstallieren.
Was ja bekanntlichermaßen
das Wichtigste ist, was man auf jeder
Linux-Distro braucht.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Okay, also wichtige Sachen sind schon mal dabei.
C-Matrix, ja das brauchen wir auch.
Brauchen Matrix-Bildschirmschoner.
Bist du eigentlich ein Virtual-Reality-Fan?
Ich hab keine 3D-VR-Brille.
Jawoll!
Jetzt ist der Hackerman glücklich.
Jetzt bräuchte ich mal ordentliche
Hackerman-Musik im Hintergrund und dann passt das.
Das freut den Chat.
SL? Nee, nee, nee.
SL brauchen wir nicht. ASCII-Quarium ist wichtiger.
Ich hab's eh...
SL ist ja die Bahn, die
übers Terminal fährt, dann ist mir das
Aquarium lieber.
SL liegt sogar standardmäßig drauf.
Okay, SL.
Wo ist das überhaupt?
Extra. SL.
Wo ist es denn? Okay, einfach Pac-Man.
Jawoll, da ist er.
Was ist die
Boot-Time?
Das Booten geht tatsächlich relativ schnell,
aber das sagt jetzt nix aus,
weil
das ja in HVM ist.
Das ist der Scam-Train, genau.
Den man übrigens nicht canceln kann.
Drück 0 in C-Matrix.
Was passiert denn dann?
Bist du noch mit dem Friseurbefall klar?
Wir kannten uns ja vorher auch schon.
Ah, yes.
Wie macht man wieder langsamer?
Ah, 9.
Wo ist der Hackerman-Modus?
Ja, das macht die...
Das fuckt die Bitrate ab, ne, Leute?
Da reicht ein 4M-Bit nicht.
Da kommt er nicht mit.
Lol.
Okay, genug jetzt.
Ja, okay, das hat mich bis jetzt
schon mal echt nicht überzeugt.
Ich würde sagen, wir probieren jetzt mal...
Ich mach jetzt hier gar nicht weiter.
Wir probieren jetzt mal die...
Die Tiling-Window-Manager-Variante.
Das ist ja für die richtigen Hackermans unter uns.
Ich guck aber vorher noch einmal schnell
ne Sache. Was hat denn bei...
Bei Visual Studio Code
für ne Version dabei? Muss ja was halbwegs
aktuelles sein, wenn es aus dem User-Repo kommt.
Ja, das ist aktuell. Oh!
Cool, er hat...
Sie haben die gleiche Tastenkombination
wie ich unter I3
für Fenster schließen. Das ist schon mal gut.
Oder nicht?
Ach nee, es ist einfach nur Windows Q.
Das ist das normale VSCode, ja?
Übrigens,
man kann nicht...
den Knopf nicht klicken, weil man ganz oben links
in der Ecke ist. Ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich
immer so Dinger entdecke.
Ah doch, geht. Das liegt an...
Okay, ich hab nichts gesagt. Das liegt an der VM.
Das liegt in der VM.
Das lag
an der VM.
Ist das immer noch Preview?
Salomon95, guck doch mal in die
letzten Videos auf dem Channel.
Da ist so ziemlich alles drin,
was wir auf dem Stream so machen.
Da ist Battlefield
am Start, da ist...
Technikstelz am Start,
da ist Kobol am Start, da ist ja alles am Start.
Ne, Wireshark.
Ja, Wireshark ist für die richtigen Herkermans.
Aber ganz ehrlich,
gut gefallen tut mir das nicht.
Da hat er Argo Linux
Tweak Tool.
Ist aber nicht drauf, oder? Ah, doch.
Was für ein Kernel.
Können wir gucken, aber ziemlich aktueller, denke ich mal.
Ja.
Ich glaube, das ist ziemlich neu.
Okay. Aha.
Und nun?
Select a Desktop.
Ja, aber wenn ich jetzt hier
sagen wir mal, den Kram nachinstallieren,
ne, dann sind es ja
ohne die Settings von denen.
Auf welcher Desktop passiert das?
Auf Arch Linux.
Hier 3
has not been installed. Warum nicht?
Was?
Beta Lockscreen
and Beta Lockscreen
get a conflict.
Oh.
Ne, das ist echt nicht gut.
Nicht schön gemacht.
Crab Themes. Okay, das ist nice.
Der Chat, was ist los?
Okay.
Wir haben jetzt zumindest ein nices Boot
Boot Wallpaper.
H-Blocker, Adblocker.
Äh, habe ich im Browser?
Neo Fetch Editor,
Pacman Config.
Themes.
Okay, wir gucken uns nochmal das schöne Crab Theme an.
Da ist es. Nice.
Aber Gandalf am Start
im Crab. Perfekt.
Der Chat.
Der scheiß Gnome.
Wenn der Kerl wüsste, ey.
Und jetzt gehen die
VMware Tools wieder nicht, oder?
Ah, okay.
Was?
What the fuck ist, was geht hier gerade ab?
Und jetzt ist das Ding wieder
links oben, nicht mehr in der Mitte?
Warum ist das jetzt auf einmal links oben?
Eben war das doch noch in der Mitte.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Okay, Leute.
Ich werde mir das jetzt nicht weiter angucken.
Ich installiere mir die andere Variante davon.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil sich die Desktop-Auflösung
geändert hat, aber man sollte eigentlich
das so programmieren, dass
man die Auflösung resizen kann
und es trotzdem noch funktioniert.
Okay, also.
Was wollen wir haben? Leute, was wollen wir verwenden?
Bisp-WM oder
Hyl-WM?
Ich glaube, das ist Herbstluft-WM.
Der Name allein schon, Alter. Gnome?
Das sagt ihr? Leute.
Wenn ich Gnome installiere,
macht ihr nur, dass ihr im Chat sagen könnt,
der scheiß Gnome.
Das weiß ich genau.
Keiner will...
Chat, Alter.
Der scheiß Gnome, Alter.
Der Chat dreht voll am Rad an.
Okay, nur für den Chat
installiere ich jetzt...
Nein, ich starte nur die Live-CD.
Ich starte nur die Live-CD, das reicht.
Wir müssen das nicht installieren.
Okay, äh.
Please, Download starten. Wir laden einfach beide schon mal runter.
Also, was? HL-WM wollten wir haben, ne?
Danach.
Okay.
Okay. Also, die Distro hat mich
bis jetzt nicht so wirklich überzeugt.
Zumindest nicht in der XFCE-Variante.
Ähm.
Was habt ihr gegen Gnome?
Nix! Das hat überhaupt nix mit
Gnome Desktop zu tun.
Na, Sana, wir hatten mal
einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit.
Wir hatten einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit,
der hat seinen Desktop so eingestellt,
dass wenn er mit der Maus
an den Bildschirmrand gekommen ist,
dass sein PC-Speaker
gesummt hat. Das heißt, er ist an den
Bildschirmrand gekommen und sein PC-Speaker
hat gemacht bzzzt.
So, und dann hat er immer gesagt,
es wäre der Gnome, der scheiße
eingestellt ist.
Das wäre quasi sein Gnome-Desktop,
der das macht. Das heißt, er hat gerade bzzzt
und dann hat er gesagt, der scheiß Gnome.
Jedes Mal.
Leko, 5 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Sorry, Leute, falls ich irgendwelche Subs übersehen habe.
Ich war gerade zu abgelenkt
durch den scheiß Gnome.
Ich scroll mal schnell durch. Der Chat ist ja so
am rumspammen mit dem
Schwachsinn.
Ich glaube, ich habe nix übersehen.
Äh, äh, ins Veto.
Zu NRW kann ich nicht viel sagen.
Ruby-Stream. Ruby-Stream
können wir jederzeit machen. Ruby, beste
Programmiersprache, nehmen wir C-Sharp.
Zumindest meine.
Lieblingssprache nehmen wir C-Sharp.
So, hat er downloadet?
Nein, hat noch nicht ganz downloadet.
Oh man, aber das hat sich
bis jetzt, also hat
mich bis jetzt noch nicht so wahnsinnig überzeugt.
Haben die denn Reddit?
Gucken wir, wie viel da los ist.
Oh, da können wir mal gucken. Da wird bestimmt geflamed.
Beautiful Linux Desktop. Wenn der genau so
gut funktioniert wie der XFCE Desktop,
dann mal außen vor.
Wish I had a dollar for every art space.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Da hat er recht.
Also ich muss euch
ehrlich sagen, man kann auf der China
Distro so lange rumhaten, wie man will.
Also
Usability und so
Gesamtkonzept hat mir deep in
von allen Linux Distros bisher am besten
gefallen. Trotz China Linux.
Okay, wir starten einfach mal
die Live-CD, dass der Chat sich nochmal
mit dem scheiß Gnome lustig machen kann.
Ups.
Jetzt müssen wir mal warten, bis es gestartet ist.
Was hat das mit
1, 2 und 3 auf sich?
Was? Wie? Wo? Hä?
Wupp Gnome und Wupp Ruby. Das kommt noch.
Das können wir noch machen.
Hallo? Ah, jetzt tut sich was.
Okay, hier kann man schon
mal auf dem Desktop gar nicht klicken.
Gibt kein Desktop. Desktop is overrated.
Display Settings funktionieren auch schon mal
nett.
Settings gehen auch nicht auf. Okay.
Excellent. Aber Startmenü
geht.
Das ist Arch-Based, ja.
Tweaks.
Okay, das funktioniert jetzt wenigstens
halbwegs. Warum die Settings nicht
aufgehen, weiß ich nicht.
Merkwürdig. Also
noch was suchen wir dann. Firefox.
Browser.
Ich habe
keinen Browser. Zumindest nicht in der
Live-CD.
Aber ein VLC gibt es.
Kein Browser, aber... Ah, doch. Hier ist er
doch. Brave. Alles klar.
Der Chat dreht voll am
Rad, Alter. Okay, Fenster
Resize. Konnte man unter Gnome nicht Fenster
Resize mit Alt und mittlerer Maustaste?
Oder Alt-Rechtsklick oder so?
Telefoniert Deepin
eigentlich nach Haus? Ich weiß es nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Deswegen sage ich ja immer
dabei, wenn man damit keine Probleme hat, eine
China-Distro zu verwenden.
Ach jetzt. Jetzt geht es auf einmal.
Eben ging es nicht.
Okay, die Gnome-Variante.
Aber das... Die Themes?
Ich weiß nicht.
Aber die Gnome-Variante
scheint ein bisschen
schlüssiger, besser in sich
zu funktionieren. Ja, da geht das Resizen
auch und sowas.
Aber jetzt
müssen wir die Hacker-Variante
installieren. Alter, Chat
kriegt euch wieder ein, sonst müsst ihr 8 Stunden
What's New in PHP 8 angucken.
So.
Ähm...
Also jetzt gucken wir mal, ob wir damit
klarkommen.
Ach du Scheiße. Ja, ja?
Ja. Anyway.
Reboot.
Power off.
Monarch S. Aber richtig
Monarch S. Wow.
Ah ja gut, ich habe ihm gerade die CD
rausgerissen. Das war keine allzu
nette Geste von mir. Das gebe ich
zu. Restart.
CD. Moment, jetzt ist das CD
nicht gemountet. Auch gut.
Haben wir das Richtige gemountet?
DHL
ISO. CD.
Start.
Jetzt komme ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr klar,
Chat. Jetzt komme ich wahrscheinlich
gar nicht mehr klar, weil
den Window Manager habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Wie gesagt, ihr wisst, dass ich
i3-Fan bin.
Aber den Teil, den Window Manager
habe ich noch nie verwendet. Wahrscheinlich weiß ich
jetzt noch nicht mal, wie man ein Fenster aufmacht.
Oh, geht da schon mal gut los.
Mit einfach nicht
Oh doch. Guck mal, es gibt
ein Fenster. Das laggt.
Alter, das laggt.
What the fuck.
Massive lag.
Extreme lag.
Keine Art Veränderer. Okay, das sind unterschiedliche
Desktops.
Okay.
Finde ich ganz nice.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage.
Was ist ein Run Dialog?
Ach, guck mal, Keybindings.
Super W ist ein Browser.
Oh, was ist das?
Oh, huiuiui.
Das ist ja mal hier.
Massive Graphics.
Das ist quasi
der Task Manager.
In
Aski oder so.
Fast in Aski.
Alter, Youtube.
Mach keine Kack Popups. Geh mir nicht auf den Sack.
Oder ist das
die Netzwerkbandbreite?
Das könnte auch die Netzwerkbandbreite sein.
Welcher WM ist das?
Das müsste jetzt Herbstluft WM sein.
Ich glaube mal, dass HLWM und Herbstluft-WM das gleiche ist.
Ist das die Netzwerkbandbreite oder ist das die CPU-Auslastung?
Pains Champ News.
Oh, die offizielle Seite von diesem Window-Manager sieht natürlich exquisite aus.
Nicht Herbstlust.
Herbstluft.
Herbstlust.
Herbstluft-WM.
Ah, yes.
Das ist eine gute Webseite, Leute.
Endlich mal wieder wie 1995.
Ja.
So müssen Webseiten aussehen.
Vor allem diese Schriftart und diese Schriftgröße ist richtig 2020.
Ja.
Ja, Chat, da geht mir auch eine ab, wenn ich die Webseite sehe.
Okay, nee, das ist die CPU-Auslastung hier gerade.
Okay.
Ähm, ja.
Gut, wie installiere ich das jetzt?
Terminal, super, Enter.
Okay, die Fonts fehlen.
Vielleicht sollte ich doch.
Mal installieren.
Super E ist Visual Studio Code.
Standardmäßig drauf, okay.
Äh, startet aber nicht.
Super D ist was.
Macht auch nix, okay.
Und Terminal, super, Enter.
Äh, was ist denn das?
Termite oder so?
Ich weiß es gerade nicht.
Ist Brave eigentlich ein brauchbarer Browser?
Ah, nee.
Urxft ist es.
So.
Wie kriege ich den Installer?
Ich habe den jetzt wieder gestartet, nachdem ich den zugeklickt habe.
Gar nicht wahrscheinlich.
Da muss ich wahrscheinlich neu starten.
Okay, ich reboote mal.
Das habe ich eine ganze Weile verwendet früher.
Urxft.
Wegen Unicode-Support.
Ordentlichem.
Aber das ist mittlerweile ziemlich ins Hintertreffen geraten.
Und fühlt sich komisch an, wenn man andere Terminals gewöhnt ist.
Weil das, ich glaube, UXVT, äh, URXVT
verwendet die gleiche Font-Rendering-Terminal.
Und Render-Rendering-Geschichte, wie Emacs.
Und deswegen fühlt sich auch Emacs merkwürdig an, wenn, was Sachen markieren angeht und sonst was.
Und ich glaube, die hatten bis vor kurzem auch keinen Emoji-Support.
Was ja für mich, was halt für mich das Allerwichtigste ist, Emoji-Support im Terminal, ja.
Oh, ich kack, Noob.
Ich habe das Falsche gestartet.
Ich muss, wollte ja von CD starten.
Xterm, oh, hör mal auf.
Man kann es ja noch übertreiben.
Xterm hat aber, finde ich, noch so seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Ähm, Xterm kann halt irgendwie jeden auch noch so abgetreten Oldschool-Scheiß, ja.
Okay.
Run Calamares, jawohl.
Runner die Calamares.
By the way, die Schrift ist deutlich schöner und lesbarer als in der XFCE-Variante.
Okay, American English, wir überspringen das jetzt einfach mal alles, weil wir können ja immer noch nachinstallieren.
Äh, ja.
Jop, jop, jop, jop, jop, jop, jop, äh, German.
Und dann, no dead keys, alles klar.
Partitions, erase all.
No swap, next.
Your full name, hatten wir doch schon.
Cute chat.
Ja, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Äh, alles klar, next, install, zack.
Oh, okay, jetzt können wir uns wieder den, den, das, das Naruto-Cosplay angucken.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn ich das jetzt doppelt starte?
Ähm, kackt der dann ab?
Okay, das ist, glaube ich, keine gute Idee zu partitionieren, während er da am Start ist.
Es sind zwei Bilder, ja, mehr, mehr, mehr war im Budget nicht drin.
Zwei Bilder auf Fiverr beauftragt, muss reichen.
Ja, da sieht man, dass es nicht alles ist, wenn der Desktop auf den ersten Blick beautiful aussieht.
Weil, was bedeuten das?
Man hat ein ordentliches Icon-Theme ausgewählt, man hat sich ein ordentliches Hintergrundbild rausgesucht.
Und dann sieht es beautiful aus.
Die Frage ist halt, wie gut vorkonfiguriert und benutzbar das Ganze ist.
Und, also, zumindest die XFCE-Variante hat bei mir jetzt extrem gefailt.
Ach, die haben den Rechtsstreit mit Nintendo noch einkalkuliert für das, für das, wie heißt denn dieses Pokémon eigentlich auf, ähm, auf Deutsch?
Ist das Shiggy oder so?
Nee, wie heißt denn das?
Ist das Shiggy?
Alter, ich als Pokémon-Noob weiß wenigstens, weiß, dass das Shiggy ist, Alter.
Ist immer massive, big.
Nur durch die ganzen, durch die ganzen Subs wusste ich das jetzt, weil ansonsten habe ich von Pokémon ja echt keinen Plan.
Musst du nicht das OS löschen?
Nee, ich habe ja gesagt, der soll alles für mich löschen.
Also, die XFCE-Variante hat mich nicht überzeugt.
EisWM.
Hey, EisWM habe ich früher sogar mal verwendet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das noch kennt.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Windows 95, Windows 95 aus EisWM.
Ja.
Das habe ich früher sogar mal verwendet, EisWM.
Ich meine, es sieht halt auch wirklich aus wie früher, ne?
Ja, das habe ich früher mal verwendet.
Und zwar, ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, ich hatte mal vor, und das ist wirklich schon ganz, ganz lange her,
also irgendwie fragt mich nicht, 2003 oder 2002 oder so,
da hatte ich noch einen ganz, ganz alten Pentium 2400 ausgebuddelt und wollte da Linux drauf laufen lassen.
Und da hatte ich auch irgendwas mit EisWM drauf.
Da war Kobol neu.
Leute, ich glaube, dort, wo Kobol neu war, das hat keiner von uns im Chat erlebt.
Kobol war neu, so 1970 oder so.
Also, da waren die richtigen Boomer am Start.
Nicht die Leute, die man heute so lustigerweise als Boomer bezeichnet.
Als die mitbekommen haben, wann Kobol neu war, das waren die richtigen Boomer.
Ja.
Das war ein Stream.
Nächsten Weihnachten, Leute, nächsten Weihnachten.
Ich habe jetzt Zeit.
Ich kann mich jetzt mit allem rausreden, nächsten Weihnachten.
Ja, war Kobol, DevOps.
Ey, über das Video haben sich viele Leute aufgeregt, ja?
Und haben gesagt, wie kann ich es wagen, zu behaupten, die Leute würden nur wegen dem Geld wegen arbeiten gehen.
Hat wirklich jemand geschrieben.
Das ist bei IT ja überhaupt nicht relevant.
Ich weiß nicht, wegen was ihr arbeiten geht, aber...
Ich würde mal behaupten, die allermeisten, wenn ihnen die Firma nicht gerade gehört, gehen wegen Geld arbeiten.
Ich arbeite auch nur just for fun, ja, genau.
Ich sage nicht, dass es nur Geld ist, ja?
Also, nicht hundertprozentig ausschließlich Geld.
Also, sagen wir mal so, so Arbeitsatmosphäre und generell, das Umfeld ist schon nicht unwichtig.
Aber, ähm...
Geld macht den größten Teil des Anreizes aus, Arbeit zu machen.
Arbeit zu gehen, ja?
Okay, restart.
Fort am Street Park.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Jetzt fangt nicht schon, jetzt fangt nicht schon am 2. Januar an mit, was wir nächsten Weihnachten für einen Stream machen müssen.
So, jetzt haben wir ihn installed.
Okay, also, wie bedient man den Kram jetzt?
VS Code, super, super und E drücken.
Was aber nichts bringt, was...
So, das muss doch irgendein Startmenü haben.
Also, ich habe die Menü, irgendeine die Menü-Variante.
Ach so, die Menü, steht doch sogar da.
Super, Shift, W.
Ah, yes.
Excellent, excellent.
Da kann man schon mal gucken.
Okay, das ist aber, das ist aber das ganz primitive, oldschool, billig, ähm, D-Menü.
Ah, Rofi haben sie auch am Start.
Okay, super, Shift, D.
Da ist schon mal...
Ah, ja, damit komme ich schon besser zurecht, ja.
Zwar ein bisschen klein, aber immerhin.
Ups.
Ah, ne, sterben hier live on, on Stream.
Adblock.
Oh, gibt's nicht.
Fail to execute Adblock.
Okay, mit den Keybindings komme ich noch nicht so ganz klar, aber das liegt daran, weil ich meine I3 Keybindings gewöhnt bin.
Super, Shift, D.
Brave ist drauf, okay.
Schon gleich mit Dark Theme, okay, okay.
Excellent.
Was ist denn die Standard-Suchmaschine, 0W?
Google.
Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, die machen auch gleich irgendwie Duck, Duck, Go oder sowas.
Oh.
Ähm, so switcht man Desktops?
Oh, ich muss sagen, also, wenn man, wenn man I3 gewöhnt ist, okay, wie verschiebt man, okay, das ist der Effekt, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das funktioniert, wie man die Fenster verschiebt.
Ja gut, da müsste man sich jetzt damit beschäftigen.
Aber, but why?
Ich bin ja mit meinem I3 zufrieden.
So.
Oh.
Pascal Stream.
Ich kann nicht jede noch so olle Programmiersprache irgendwann mal machen.
Okay, aber Desktop-Switchen ist schon mal nice.
Das ist, das ist exakt, wie ich es auch bei mir unter I3 habe, das ist cool.
Jetzt wüsste ich noch gerne, wie ich Fenster verschiebe.
Okay, Fenster verschieben geht so.
Alles klar.
Die Frage ist nur, wie?
Was?
Windows, Shift, plus File.
Ja, das ist, das ist Fenster verschieben in dem Fall.
Aber, ich habe, wie kann ich die, die Größe von den Fenstern verändern?
Unten geht es nicht.
Zack, zack.
Gibt es auch sowas wie einen Resize-Mode?
Äh.
Okay.
Ich habe keinen Plan, wie man Fenster resizet oder wie man Fenster in Window-Mode schaltet.
Gibt es da eine Config?
Config?
Äh.
Alles klar.
Windows-R.
Windows-R habe ich schon probiert, das ist Resize in I3, ja, aber das geht hier nicht.
Okay, keine Ahnung, wie es geht.
Wie resized man da?
Resize.
Button-Action.
Ja, das, das probiere ich ja, das geht ja nicht.
Resizen, resizen tut es ja nicht.
Erlang-Stream.
Jetzt kommt als nächstes Brain-Fuck-Stream.
Mod-Control-J.
Äh.
Du kannst den Window-Mode nicht resizen.
Ja, aber.
Ich muss doch sagen können, dass das hier kleiner sein soll, als das.
Okay, das schiebe ich jetzt nicht auf die Config, da schiebe ich das da drauf, dass ich keine.
Resize.
Alter, ist das jetzt für irgendwelche, das sieht aus wie irgendwelche Mathe-Formeln oder so.
Das ist, okay.
Ex, also das ist schon wirklich Next-Level-Shit, um einfach zu sagen, wie man ein Fenster resizes.
Mod-Shift und dann Pfeil nach rechter, das ist verschieben.
Okay, ich bin da zu dumm für, aber das liegt, wie gesagt, an mir, weil ich das Ding noch nicht verwendet habe.
Okay, aber, aber man muss ja mal ihn so gut halten, dass das prinzipiell jetzt anscheinend ganz gut funktioniert.
Das ist der Network-Manager, jup.
Das sieht sogar auch echt ganz hübsch gemacht aus, also das könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen zu verwenden.
Außer vielleicht Brave.
Erstmal Firefox installieren.
Das.
Passt, Tor-Browser.
Erstmal Firefox installieren und dann Chrome installieren.
Gibt's ein Linux, auf dem alle Games laufen?
Nein.
Games unter Linux ist eh so ein Ding.
Wenn du Glück hast, funktioniert's.
Mittlerweile funktioniert ja einiges.
Halbwegs.
Aber wenn du problemlos spielen willst, bleibt dir nichts anderes aus, äh, nichts anderes übrig, außer Windows zu verwenden.
Zwei Pfeile gleichzeitig drücken?
Nee, das geht auch nicht.
Du musst Windows verwenden.
Ja, dir bleibt nichts anderes übrig.
Also, wenn du wirklich sicher gehen willst, dass die Spiele funktionieren, auch im Multiplayer,
und du auch neue Sachen direkt bei Release spielen können möchtest,
dann bleibt dir nichts anderes übrig, außer Windows.
Kontext-Menü-Taste.
Ja, die wird's sein.
Guck mal.
Guck mal, was die Kontext-Menü-Taste tolles fabriziert.
Ja, also das ist ganz in Ordnung vorkonfiguriert.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Was ist das?
Was?
Diskret?
Ist das Discord?
Discord?
Ich weiß nicht was.
Ich weiß nicht, was uns das hier oben sagen soll.
Da bin ich zu small-brained für.
CPU-Festplatte, Kalender, okay.
Man kann ausschalten.
Man kann Q-Chat rebooten.
Okay.
Gibt's nicht irgendeine Software, die automatisch nur VM mit Windows öffnet, wenn ich ein Game auf Linux starte?
Das kannst du mit Sicherheit machen, allerdings laufen Games in der VM nicht ordentlich.
Außer alte Games.
Sehr alte Games.
Ja, okay, das ist doch jetzt ganz nett.
Was war hier?
Was war Start-Menü?
Super-Shift-D.
Das kann man verwenden.
Das kann man benutzen, das finde ich in Ordnung.
Was halt ein bisschen doof ist, dass ich nicht weiß, wie man Fenster resized.
Das wäre schon ganz nice zu wissen, dass das dann nicht so aussieht.
Ja, das ist ganz nett, das gefällt mir.
Wie gesagt, das würde ich verwenden.
Ja, das würde ich verwenden.
Allerdings ist mir ganz ehrlich mein ordentlich konfiguriertes i3 mit Tiling-Window-Manager halt lieber.
Kann man nicht GPU-Pass-Through für Games auf einer VM machen?
Nee, nicht, wenn du unter Windows bist.
Achso, wenn du unter Linux bist.
Äh, ja, wenn du unter Linux bist, kann man das machen, wobei das andere Probleme mit sich bringt.
Ja, da musst du dir nämlich überlegen, wie kriegst du beispielsweise die Maus in die VM?
Also, wie kriegst du die Maus in die VM?
Wie willst du, ne?
Also, du brauchst ja Input in der VM für das Game, weil du hast ja dann direkt ein Output auf den Monitor.
Du hast ja dann keine VM mehr in einem Fenster, sondern du hast einen eigenen Monitor dran, wo dann die VM draufkommt, wenn du GPU-Pass-Through drauf machst.
Dann musst du auch noch eine Maus- und Tastatur-Pass-Throughen und dann wird es ein bisschen eng auf dem Schreibtisch.
Dann kannst du dir im Endeffekt auch zwei Rechner hinstellen.
Vielleicht muss man eine VM programmieren, die auf sowas optimiert ist.
Das Problem ist gar nicht so sehr.
Dass man das machen müsste.
Die Sache ist die, das ist nicht so ohne.
Weil, du müsstest ja dann eine vollständige Grafikkarte emulieren, die DirectX 12 und Vulkan kompatibel ist.
Und das performant machen, das kannst du knicken.
Also, die tun sich ja schon mit DirectX und älterem OpenGL in VM wäre richtig schwer.
Das wird keiner programmieren.
Ich habe auch so meine Zweifel, ob das überhaupt möglich ist, dass das ordentlich funktioniert.
Gerade, weil DirectX 12 und Vulkan ja nur wirklich nichts Unkomplexes sind.
Ne, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Wie gesagt, du kannst GPU-Pass-Through machen, aber damit kriegst du wieder ganz andere Probleme.
Und die Sache ist halt die, musst halt mal überlegen, wenn du eine VM starten willst, mit Windows drauf, um da drin dann zu spielen.
Selbst wenn wir mal von ausgehen.
Würde.
Das geht.
Das heißt, du brauchst nach wie vor Windows.
Was im Umkehrschluss wieder heißt, du kannst doch auch Windows verwenden und darauf eine VM laufen lassen, so wie ich es hier beispielsweise mache.
Dann hast du nämlich alle Vorteile von Windows und so ziemlich alle Vorteile von Linux.
Weil Linux läuft in der VM absolut top.
Du merkst, also ich benutze tagtäglich auf der Arbeit Linux.
Und ich merke zwischen der Linux-VM hier und meinem Arbeitslaptop.
Kaum einen Unterschied.
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil unsere Arbeitslaptops jetzt nicht die Allerschnellsten sind, ja.
Das kommt auch noch dabei, genau.
Um GPU-Pass-Through zu machen, brauchst du auch ein gescheites Board, da macht ja jeder Hersteller so ein bisschen, legt ja die PCI-Spezifikation und Sachen so ein bisschen nach Kudünken aus.
Und wenn du Pech hast, passthroughst du dann auf einmal drei PCI-Geräte, obwohl du eigentlich schon die Grafikkarte durchreichen willst und sowas.
Und Dual-Boot will man nicht machen.
Dual-Boot hast du das Problem, dass du quasi laufend hin und her switchen musst zwischen verschiedenen Betriebs, das ist auch nervig.
Also, ich kann es euch hier empfehlen.
Die beste Variante ist, installiert euch den Windows und macht darauf vor allem eine Workstation mit einer Linux-VM.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist ein Aquarium-Bildschirmschoner.
Den ich als einfach nur mal angemacht habe, just for fun.
Es ist kein, es ist kein ASCII-Angel-Game oder so.
Ich hole jetzt hier nicht den Fisch in die Hand.
Ich hole jetzt hier nicht den Fisch gerade raus.
Mach keine Achievements.
Achievements unlocked.
Ja, also das ist meiner Meinung nach die beste Variante.
Wenn du wirklich spielen willst und da auch Fokus drauf liegt und du willst, dass Multiplayer-Spiele problemlos funktionieren und dass neue Spiele beim Release problemlos funktionieren, installiert Windows und installiert die Linux in der VM.
Aber guck mal.
Und wenn mir eine ankommt mit Dual-Boot, so schnell wie ich hier zwischen meinem Windows und meinem Linux wechsle, machst du mit Dual-Boot.
So schnell wie ich hier zwischen meinem Windows und meinem Linux wechsle, machst du mit Dual-Boot.
Dann hast du mit Dual-Boot nichts.
Dazu kommt, dass du den ganzen Kram neu starten musst und das einfach nervig ist.
Das macht man nicht.
Das hört sich in der Theorie gut an, aber praktisch gesehen macht mans nicht.
Dann musst du noch dein Passwort eingeben, weil du vollverschlüsselt hast.
Also eine VM mit Linux auf Windows.
Dann startet die VM automatisch, sodass man immer direkt im ...
What?
Warum, warum?
Also du kannst das sicherlich so einrichten, dass die VM automatisch startet.
Aber sag mal so, die 5 Sekunden
VMware Workstation aufzumachen
hat man ja eigentlich.
Wie sieht das bei
VMware mit Multi-Monitor-Support aus?
Geht, benutze ich
aber nicht, deswegen kann ich ja nicht so viel zu sagen.
Genau, wenn man
Windows selten braucht, dann
kann man das machen.
Also mal angenommen, ich würde zu
90% oder Linux arbeiten, ab und zu
müsste ich mal Windows starten, um irgendwie mal
schnell was zu machen, dann würde
ich das auch so machen mit Doodleboot,
aber aktuell
benutze ich halt quasi
genauso oft Windows wie
Linux Sachen. Und da
ist das nervtankt.
Das Schöne ist, jetzt kann im Endeffekt jeder machen,
was er will. Ich sage euch
nur, wie es bei mir ist und so wie ich das mache
und alles andere
wird mir auf den Nerven gehen.
Mac Mini, exzellent.
Ich habe mir auch vor ein paar Jahren schon mal überlegt,
ob ich mir ein Mac Mini holen soll.
Was ist das? Darf man das
aufmachen?
Oder ist das TOS, Leute?
Ah ne, das sind die Keys. Ne, ne, das zeige
ich hier nicht im Stream.
Keine Serial Keys hier liegen
im Stream, sonst ist Monka TOS und BUN
und wollen wir ja nicht.
Klar. Meinst du,
die finden das geil? Guck mal, die sind
bei Twitch so schaft drauf aktuell, was
Urheberrechtssachen angeht, die finden es
bestimmt nicht toll, wenn man irgendwelche Serial Keys
zeigt. Ja, aber guck mal,
also hiermit kommt man echt ganz gut klar.
Das ist ja
quasi so, wie ich
mein Lelux-Zeug eingerichtet habe.
Wunderbar. Und ich denke, man
kommt auch hier mit Heftors klar,
wenn man hier den Tiling Window Manager
verwendet. Wobei ich sagen muss,
die XFCE-Variante hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Und wie gesagt,
ich habe eh keinen Grund umzusteigen, weil
mein Manjaro mit E3
halt gut funktioniert. Habe ich euch
heute eigentlich schon mal meine
Heizungsüberwachung gezeigt?
Wo man jetzt erkennen kann,
dass ich gerade
Heißwassertemperatur habe,
55 Grad,
voll das Unding, dass Prime Video unter Linux
nur mit 84p funktioniert. Ja,
also ich wusste gar nicht, dass
Prime Video nur mit 84p funktioniert, aber
das ist ein allgemeines Problem, was du
unter Linux hast, wenn es um Multimedia-Sachen
geht. Vieles ist da ein bisschen hinten dran.
Guck mal, was das
für ein ewig, ewiger,
ewiges Hin und Her
und Riesenakt immer noch ist,
dass du Grafikkarten,
Dekoder verwenden kannst, also Video-Dekoder
mit der Grafikkarte machen kannst im Browser
unter Linux.
Das funktioniert ja bis heute nicht richtig
und dann nur in einer ganz speziellen
Kombination und dann auch nicht für alle
Videokodex. Also
das ist
alles nicht so schön, ja.
Linux hat eindeutig seine Vorteile,
aber
Umgang
interop mit irgendwelchem
Stonkszeug
ist es nicht, ja.
Das
mag ein DRM-Problem sein, das ist so,
es kann, gehe ich sogar mal ganz stark von aus,
dass es ein DRM-Problem ist und dass die
Hersteller einfach kein Interesse haben
da dran, das ordentlich zu machen.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist es halt für
den User trotzdem scheiße.
Und die Hersteller
haben halt da nicht viel Priorität drauf.
Und das wird auch so sein. Ich meine, guckt euch das
mal an. Guckt euch mal an,
die Desktop-Verbreitung,
äh, das meinte ich jetzt eigentlich
gar nicht. By the way,
mir tun die Augen weh, äh,
ihr OS-Market-Share.
So, guckt euch das mal an. Was ist das
obere? Android.
Das nächste? Windows. Da muss ich gar nicht unten
hingucken. Guckt mal, ob das stimmt. Android, Windows,
ja. In Deutschland, witzigerweise,
jetzt sieht es ein bisschen anders aus, können wir uns gleich,
können wir uns gleich angucken.
Danach iOS,
danach Mac,
und irgendwo hier unten
da gräbst Linux
rum. Da muss man sich nicht
fragen, warum die Hersteller als wenig Priorität
haben, da was dran zu ändern.
Was,
was, ein File? Fail von Microsoft?
Wieso, was ist das?
So viel Open Source steckt in Windows.
Äh.
Warum ist das ein Fail von Microsoft?
Will das jetzt nicht alles,
alles lesen müssen?
Linux-Server mit dabei, naja,
das, nachdem das eine Auswertung
über Browser ist, kannst du davon ausgehen, das ist
Desktop-Systeme.
Der UWP ist generell
Fail. Und Microsoft hat mich ja auch echt
enttäuscht, ne. Ich hab mich ja so drauf
gefreut, dass endlich WinUI
3 rauskommt.
Und Microsoft
hat jetzt gesagt, ne, Unpackaged-App gibt's
nicht. Es gibt einfach keine
Unpackaged-Desktop-Apps. Das ist das,
was die Leute damit machen wollen.
Um den ganzen UWP-Shit
und Code-Signing-Zertifikate
loszuwerden. Warum sieht das
überhaupt so kacke aus hier?
Aber da hat sich Microsoft gesagt, ne, ne, in diesem
Preview machen wir das nicht, obwohl sie das für
Preview 3 angekündigt haben.
Ich weiß nicht,
wann das Ganze, wann das Ganze erscheint.
Hast du Bitcoin? Ne.
Aber ich glaub, der Keeper XY hat Bitcoin.
Hast du nicht, warst du nicht
so Kryptowährung-mäßig am Start?
Oder bring ich das jetzt durcheinander?
Also, ne, Market Share.
Hier, Desktop, Linux.
Excellent.
1%, jawoll.
Du hast dein Wallet nicht mehr? Sag bloß,
du warst bei...
Ich hoffe nicht.
Übrigens, Leute, wenn ich mir diesen Market Share
so anguck,
von, von, ähm,
1%, glaubt
ihr auch,
glaubt ihr auch, dass
2021 das Jahr des
Linux-Desktops wird?
So wie jedes Jahr, na klar, ja.
Ach so, 0,03 Bit...
äh...
Bitcoin.
Ja, ich mein,
was werden das mittlerweile?
40.000 mal
0,03.
Ups.
Immerhin, 1,2k.
Kann man aber verkraften, besser als
40k.
Ah, ne, ich kann jetzt den Namen nicht sagen.
Aber du weißt vielleicht,
wen ich mein, der bei uns auf der Arbeit
groß rumgeprotzt hat,
mit seinem Bitcoin-Wallet.
Der, der jetzt nicht mehr da ist.
Ja.
Der hat's ja auch verkackt, der hat ja auch kein Wallet mehr gehabt.
Der hat irgendwie
16 Bitcoin oder sowas.
Der hätte heut richtig massig Kohle, ey.
Tja, man sollte auf
sein Wallet aufpassen.
Ich mein, überleg mal, 16 Bitcoin, was sind das?
16 mal...
Alter!
Oh, der ärgert sich, ey.
Wie kann man sein Wallet einfach verlieren?
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Der Typ, der war eh ein bisschen, ähm...
sehr überheblich.
Und irgendwie hat er zusammen
mit nem Kollege was gemacht.
Und er hat irgendwie gemein und sein Kollege
hat irgendwie das Wallet da gemacht.
Und keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht hat er auch einfach nur Mist erzählt.
Aber angeblich hat er nen Wallet gehabt
mit 16 Bitcoins.
Und das... keine Ahnung.
Kann er nicht mal drauf zugreifen oder sonstwas.
Vielleicht hat er auch einfach nur Mist erzählt.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Wobei ich mir das bei dem tatsächlich vorstellen kann,
der hat bei jedem Hype-Scheiß mitgemacht.
Und er ist auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Also der war auf jeden Fall auch am Start,
als er die Bitcoins meinen konnte.
Ist das der scheiß Gnome?
Nein, das ist die 3WM.
Die Pizza, die mit Bitcoin gekauft wurde.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich mein, mir ist auch klar,
dass man das nicht so...
eigentlich
nicht so sehen darf, ja.
Zum damaligen Zeitpunkt haben die die Pizza angeboten
und beide Seiten waren damit einverstanden.
Aber trotzdem wird es mich trotzdem ärgern.
Pizza oder 40.000 Euro.
Oder was haben wir denn aktuell gerade?
Bitcoin-Kurs.
Ah, okay.
Wie komme ich denn auf 40.000?
Wir sind gerade bei
30.000.
Und KeeperXY, freust du dich schon wieder aufs Arbeiten
nächste Woche?
Weiß nicht, ob du Urlaub hattest.
Ich kann mich ja kaum halten, ne?
Alter, guckt euch das mal an hier.
Hier haben sie das letzte Mal
schon rum geflamed.
So nach dem Motto, oh nee,
die Bitcoin-Blase
und bla und sonstwas.
Ja, bäm, Alter.
Also wenn das mal wieder runtergeht,
irgendwo, ohne Scheiß
dann kaufe ich auch Bitcoin. Easy.
Ich muss eh mal meine Kohle
irgendwo hin.
Nicht alles, Leute, garantiert nicht.
Ich werde da jetzt nicht irgendwie, frag mich nicht,
150k oder so in Bitcoin stecken, das mache ich nicht.
Aber
so einfach, weil es geht.
Wenn das wieder runter geht.
All in Crypto-Blase.
Ne, sowas mache ich nicht.
Sowas mache ich nicht.
Man könnte sich auch FIFA-Packs kaufen.
Das ist auch eine wahre, das ist eine sehr gute Investition, ja.
Einfach FIFA-Packs.
Oder FIFA-Coins über irgendeinen Key-Shop.
Wie sieht es eigentlich mit Monero gerade so aus?
Monero ist der Kram, den Cristiano Ronaldo bei sich auf der Homepage gemeint hat.
Oder war das Ethereal oder wie das andere heißt?
Ne, ich glaube Monero hat er gemeint.
Wobei man ja sagen muss, das garantiert nicht Cristiano Ronaldo selbst Monero gemeint hat auf seiner Webseite.
Sondern irgendwelche Big-Brain-Admins auf seiner Seite den JavaScript-Miner installiert haben.
Leute, ich hätte eigentlich die Idee, ne.
Ich mache einfach irgendeine Seite, wo die Leute den ganzen Tag drauf gehen und da rumeideln.
Und dann mache ich einen JavaScript-Miner drauf.
Und dann promote ich das wie verrückt auf YouTube.
Ich meine, guckt euch die ganzen Scammer-Shops an, die CS-Skins gesellt haben.
Mit so übelst shady Practice dahinter, ja.
Syndicate mit seinem Shop und alles mögliche.
Die haben auch übelst ein Crap gemacht und das auf ihrem YouTube promotet.
Warum soll ich das nicht auch machen?
Das war kein Shop, das war Gambling.
Er hat halt gefaked, dass man da gewinnt.
Ja, was halt auch schon echt...
Fragwürdig ist, ne.
Sie ist da und die scheißen auf ihre Fans komplett.
Lohnt sich Mining noch?
Ne.
Ne, aktuell nicht.
Zumindest nicht bei Bitcoin.
Ich habe ein Video gesehen von einem.
Das war eigentlich richtig cool.
Der hat...
Der hat nen...
Das gucken wir jetzt nicht.
Ich zeige euch nochmal was.
Bitcoin Mining Solar Power.
Hatte der?
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das war irgend so ein alter...
Alter Sack.
Ich finde es im Prinzip ist auch egal.
Zumindest, der hat nen riesen Solar Panel im Sommer im Garten stehen gehabt.
Und nen fetten Miner und ne Batterie und alles.
Und er hat es einen Tag laufen gehabt.
Und hat glaube ich...
Ich habe vergessen wie die Cent Einheit von Bitcoin heißt.
Es gibt noch was kleineres von Bitcoin.
Nicht Miyamoto, aber so ähnlich.
Wie heißt es?
Satoshi, Satoshi, genau.
Und der hat irgendwie umgerechnet 0,005 Cent oder so gemeint am Tag mit seinem Solar Panel Mining.
Also es war komplett unpraktikabel.
Ne, ne, nicht das Semper Video.
Ne, ne, ne, das meine ich nicht.
Ne, ne, der hat nicht mit seinem normalen Rechner gemeint.
Der hat sich...
Irgend so nen gebrauchten Bitcoin Miner gekauft.
So ne Kiste, die im Endeffekt nur aus Lüftern besteht.
So, und das hat sich halt überhaupt nicht gelohnt.
Übrigens, soll ich mal sagen, dass ich immer noch sehr begeistert davon bin.
Wie gut das mit der Heizung war.
Übrigens, den Raspberry Pi, den wir letztens eingebaut haben.
Äh, nicht installiert haben.
Den habe ich jetzt hier im Betrieb.
Und guckt mal, wie nice wir das im Stream eingerichtet haben.
Ich habe hier komplette, komplette Übersicht über alle Sachen.
Und ich kann jetzt auch nachgucken.
Und so weiß ich immer, dass ich beispielsweise, dass er nicht zu warm wird.
Was ja auch schon mal wichtig ist, ja.
45 Grad.
Und...
Ich sehe auch direkt, dass der RAM nicht voll läuft.
Äh, der Raspberry Pi ist mein Unify Controller und mein Webinterface für die Überwachungskameras.
Allerdings, Leute, by the way, zum Thema Überwachungskameras, ne.
Ne.
Ich habe die Kram hier zusammen im Stream mehr oder weniger zusammen, ich sage mal, zusammenprogrammiert.
Ja, ihr habt mir zugeguckt bei.
Ich habe ein Problem.
Auf dem Raspberry Pi kackt das Ding einmal am Tag ab.
Mein Überwachungskamera-Software-Ding.
Ich habe irgendwo eine Memory liegt drin und ich finde es nicht.
Und ich vermute mal, dass das irgendwo in diesem FFmpeg-Scheiß ist und ich finde es nicht.
Irgendwo hier bei FFmpeg ist das.
Und ich habe keine Ahnung wo.
Ich sehe es.
Ah, yes.
Mal kurz analysiert schnell.
Und das Problem ist, es ist kein normales Memory-Leak, weil der Arbeitsspeicher wird eigentlich gar nicht mehr.
Aber trotzdem meint .NET out of memory.
Und die eigentliche Auslastung geht nie über 170 MB RAM.
Also vermute ich mal, das liegt daran, weil irgendeine Collection zu groß wird oder sowas.
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Das muss ich erst noch mal rauskriegen.
Hast du zufällig mal gezeigt, wie man Nextcloud bei Docker Compose und Traffic korrekt installiert?
Oh, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob wir Nextcloud installiert haben.
Haben wir Nextcloud über Docker Compose installiert?
Wir haben auf jeden Fall Traffic mit Docker Compose mal installiert.
Aber ob wir Nextcloud installiert haben, weiß ich nicht.
Aber du kannst nachgucken.
Guck mal, wir haben doch ein Archive.
Woblords.tv.
Ah, nicht Wutz...
Wutzblors.
Ja, Woblords.tv.
Und da gibt es hier irgendwo das Archive.
Ah.
Und im Archive kannst du dann mal suchen.
Nochmal Docker.
Oh, haben wir nicht?
Äh...
Tja, wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wie dieser Stream hieß.
Traffic.
War es schon mal nicht.
Ach, den habe ich gelöscht, oder?
Ja, kann es sein, dass es der Stream war, wo ich irgendwas gelöscht...
Leaked habe, den ich danach gelöscht habe.
Ich habe, ich habe zwei, drei Streams gelöscht.
Also, das könnte, das könnte tatsächlich sein.
Ne?
Wir könnten, wir könnten dieser Stream...
Wir könnten dieser Stream...
Ne, den Leak meine ich nicht, GlocksHD.
Ähm...
Ich meine nicht den Recording-Ordner.
Wer war beim Recording-Ordner dabei, Chat?
Wer hat es überhaupt mitgekriegt?
Wir könnten, wir...
Okay, meine Stream-Benahmungen sind ja oftmals nicht sonderlich clever.
Das könnte durchaus sein, dass ich das einfach MonkaS genannt habe, oder so.
In welchem Stream habe ich das gemacht?
Das habe ich irgendwann hier gemacht.
Ich mag Emojis im Titel, wie man sieht.
Was war...
Ach, das war überhaupt nichts Schlimmes.
Ich habe mal...
Ich wollte mal nachgucken, Aufnahme von irgendeinem Gameplay.
Und da bin ich in den Ordner gegangen, wo...
Äh...
Shadowplay, die...
Und da war halt ein unglückliches Thumbnail drinnen von der Aufnahme.
Und da ist natürlich...
Da ist natürlich der Chat wieder komplett drauf angesprungen, ne?
Reverse Pro...
Alter, der Fips, guck mal, wie er...
Wie er das einfach rauskriegt.
Ja, das könnte es sein hier.
Reverse Proxy.
Linux Let's Encrypt einrichten.
Ja, das ist es, glaube ich.
Okay.
Stream vom...
1.7.2020.
Guck mal hier, der Chat kennt sich aus.
Was?
Aber downloaden darf ich, oder was?
Hä?
Was ist das für ein Stumpfsinn?
Aber wenn ich es doch runterladen kann, warum kann ich es dann nicht streamen?
Das ergibt doch absolut keinen Sinn.
Aber absolut null.
Er...
Irgendjemand erklären?
Wo ist der Sinn?
Wo ist der Sinn davon?
Aber guck mal, also bandbreitenmäßig kann es ja nicht dran liegen.
Ich darf es ja runterladen.
Warum darf ich es dann nicht streamen?
Hä, warum sollte er downloaden?
Soll er nicht...
Let's...
Ich meine, okay.
Streaming machst du HLS.
Das ist im Endeffekt eine Playliste mit kleinen...
Mit kleinen Segmenten.
Das macht doch keinen großen Unterschied.
Wahrscheinlich um Filmstreaming zu vermeiden.
Das könnte tatsächlich sein.
Chainloss sagt auch...
Oh, das ist nice.
Das freut mich immer.
Du hättest damals zu Amazon gehen müssen, als sie noch unlimited waren.
Ähm...
Das freut mich immer, wenn ich sowas lese.
Chainloss schreibt...
Ich hab durch...
Wahrscheinlich durch deines Streams, glaube ich, sollte er...
Ähm...
Ich hab dadurch angefangen, eine Programmiersprache zu lernen, mich als IT-Systemelektroniker bei der Telekom zu bewerben und wurde angenommen.
Danke für deinen tollen Streams.
Das ist super.
Danke, dass das geklappt hat.
Das freut mich immer, wenn ich sowas lese.
Excellent.
So, hat er das jetzt downgeloadet?
Oder ist er noch dabei?
Ah, er lädt noch.
Er lädt noch.
Ich meine, es ist schon cool, wenn man mit 45 MB die Sekunde downloadet.
Dass er freut, ja.
Wenn Vodafone einfach das macht, wofür man Geld bezahlt.
Hol dir Hetzner Storage.
Warum?
Soll ich was bezahlen, wenn ich es kostenlos kriege?
Wenn ich das wirklich jemand angucken will, kann er sich das auch runterladen.
Also so viel ist ja nicht zu viel verlangt.
Ja.
Bald 40...
Ach, stimmt.
Der Sibaro hat ja massive Hardware aufgerüstet, ja.
Keeper XY, du hast immer noch dein ZEV-Cluster daheim.
Wo wir gerade beim Thema sind, ne?
Wir hatten es doch letztens davon, die Leute, die übertreiben mit ihrem Home-Setup.
Ich kenne da auch ein paar.
Also du hast kein ZEV mehr.
Mit was machst du jetzt?
120 TB ZFS?
Oder was machst du?
Cluster?
Cluster oder...
Weiß ich nicht.
Moose FS.
So, also hier, Archive.
Zack.
Und ich bin immer noch nicht fertig geladen.
Aber gleich.
Ah, es ist ein Leute, die BTRFS verstehe.
BTRFS ist ja auch so ein Ding.
Jeder spricht es anders aus, ne?
Ich bin ja Fan von BTRFS.
Es gibt Leute, die sagen ButterFS.
Dann gibt es Leute, die sagen BetterFS.
Da gibt es ja zig Aussprachen von.
Ey, ne, ich bin für BTRFS.
So.
Also, VLC.
VLC.
Das ist jetzt fertig downgeloadet.
Jawoll.
Okay.
Also, schauen wir mal, was ich da gemacht habe im Stream.
Fängt ja schon mal gut an.
Einfach mal perfekter Start vom Stream.
Okay, was habe ich da im Stream gemacht?
Ah, Digital Ocean war das.
Okay, okay.
Aha.
So, habe ich da Nextcloud installiert irgendwo?
Traffic.
Whoam I habe ich gemacht?
Alles klar.
Whoam I?
Okay, jetzt mache ich Traffic, ähm, API-Token.
Was habe ich eigentlich gemacht?
Warum konnte ich das API-Token im Stream zeigen?
Ich konnte das API-Token im Stream zeigen, weil ich genau die Absender-IP eingestellt habe.
Ja, ja, liegt.
Aber man konnte nichts machen.
Ich habe die Absender-IP bei Cloudflare eingestellt.
Ähm, vor allem I'm in.
Das Ding gibt es ja gar nicht mehr.
Okay, Git, irgendein Git-Frontline habe ich aufgesetzt noch.
Hatte ich eine Nextcloud dabei?
Watchtower zum Updaten von Containern?
Okay.
Nee, ich glaube, Nextcloud haben wir nicht gemacht.
Übrigens, noch, noch, das müssen wir jetzt, das, das, das muss jetzt sein.
Leute.
Habe ich LoL-CAD installiert?
Wie?
Habe ich nicht?
Oder habe ich doch?
Nee, umgedreht.
So ist das noch viel besser, oder?
Das gibt, das gibt dem nochmal so den besonderen, den besonderen Kicker.
Kick dem, dem Aquarium.
Warte mal, kann man mit Traffic Let's Encrypt installieren für mehrere Dienste gleichzeitig?
Ja, ja, das ist ja der Sinn von so einem Reverse-Proxy.
Also, na gut, der Sinn von einem Reverse-Proxy ist es ja prinzipiell, ist es nicht.
Aber es bietet sich an, wenn man quasi eh schon eine zentrale Stelle hat, worüber alle, also, die am Anfang, am Eingang steht,
dass man darauf auch das Zertifikats-Handling für mehrere Dienste macht.
Ja, ja, das bietet sich an.
Was, C-Matrix?
Noch, oh, noch besser, noch besser, Leute.
Okay, jetzt, jetzt fangen wir mal die Bitrate wieder ab.
Oh, Leute, ich habe es kaputt gemacht.
Nee, jetzt.
Okay, jetzt ist die Bitrate im Arsch, oder?
Jetzt ist die Bit, jetzt ist die, jetzt ist die Bitrate, jetzt ist RIP.
Okay, das ist alles, das Wichtigste hätten wir auch schon mal geklärt.
Oh.
Ah, mein Twitch ist gerade abgeschissen, Leute.
Lull.
Hat ich einfach neu gestartet, mein Browser.
Mein Browser-Fenster mit Twitch drin, hat ich einfach neu gestartet gerade.
Äh, jetzt lädt er mal mir den Chat.
Sag mal, ist Twitch gerade wieder voll am abkacken?
Kann das sein?
Nee.
Nee, nur mein Browser spinnt rum.
Verbindung zum Chat nicht möglich.
Chat.
Geht's bei euch noch?
Könnt ihr noch chatten?
Postchamp?
Ich glaube, der Twitch-Chat ist kaputt.
Oder der Chat ist kaputt.
Wo habe ich schon mein Handy?
Jetzt muss ich mal vom Handy ausprobieren, ob es da geht.
Also, dass jetzt gar keiner was schreibt, so Dis...
Als so diszipliniert schätze ich den Twitch-Chat nicht ein.
Oh, ja.
Ja, ja, Twitch ist gerade am rumspacken.
Ich sehe es gerade in meiner Mobile-App.
Alter, das ist ja komplett im Arsch.
Monka.
Das ist komplett RIP.
Das ist komplett RIP, Twitch.
Lull.
Es geht gar nichts gerade.
Ja, Chat.
Ist jetzt schwierig, ne?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was ihr sagt.
Aber zumindest der Stream an sich scheint noch zu funktionieren.
Da bin ich ja schon mal froh.
Dass der Stream an sich funktioniert.
Sehr gut.
Ja, Chat.
Eigentlich bin ich ja durch mit dem, was ich machen wollte.
Ist da Frasier am Start?
Ei, Frisi.
Nope.
Was?
Nee, Twitch ist komplett hinüber jetzt.
Press F.
Wobei, wir können kein F pressen für Twitch.
Weil ihr könnt ja nichts machen im Chat.
Na gut.
Ich glaube, ich glaube.
Leute, ich glaube, ich gehe jetzt einfach off.
Diese komische Distro habe ich jetzt ausprobiert.
Die hat mich zumindest in XFCE überhaupt nicht überzeugt.
Andere, ja.
Kann man benutzen.
Wobei ich ja, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich bin ja happy mit meinem E3 Manjaro Konstrukt.
Ich sollte das vielleicht mal löschen.
Den Download hier.
Ich meine, ich brauche ja nicht.
Wow.
Lolcat hat es ein bisschen kaputt gemacht.
Äh, wir löschen mal.
Ich meine, ich muss hier keine 8 Gigabyte.
Keine 8 Gigabyte Stream rumliegen haben.
Einfach so, weil es funktioniert.
So, letzter Versuch.
Geht der Chat wieder?
Ah.
Leute, der Chat geht wieder angeblich.
Angeblich geht der Chat wieder.
Ich konnte gerade Test schreiben.
Mon KS.
Aber mein OBS lädt.
Mein OBS lädt.
Aber mein OBS lädt schon mal nicht.
Chat.
Nee, ne?
Oh.
Jetzt ist komplett vorbei.
Wir wissen ja.
Möglichst oftest, möglichst häufiges Refreshen sorgt dafür, dass es schneller wieder funktioniert.
Ups.
Funktioniert.
Ich kann euch das aus eigener Erfahrung sagen.
Als Anbieter von irgendwelchen Webdiensten mag man es eigentlich nicht, wenn die User wie verrückt refreshen.
Wie verrückt refreshen.
Aber nachdem wir ja hier.
ganz normaler User sind, machen wir es einfach trotzdem.
Also in meinem anderen
Browserfenster bin ich connected
zum Chat und das funktioniert. Aber ich
sehe von euch nichts und ich sehe von mir
auch nichts im anderen Fenster
jetzt. Also scheint es so halb
zu gehen. Oder auch
gar nicht. Was macht denn das Ganze
unter Linux? Geht es unter Linux jetzt?
Ah ja.
Dann würde ich fast sagen, ich mache jetzt Schluss.
Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid.
Leider nicht so erfolgreich, wie ich mir das
vorgestellt habe, weil die Distro gefällt mir nicht.
Power off.
Äh, ausgehen please.
Ausgehen please.
Sehr gut.
Letzter Test.
Chat.
Connecting to Chat.
Gibt kein Chat Connect.
Na gut. Also, dann
sehen wir uns. Macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Morgen früh, oder?
Ja, morgen früh geht's
schon weiter. Alles klar, bis dann.
Macht's gut. See you.